- ยินดีต้อนรับกลับมาที่ "ทำความเข้าใจ
ข้อมูลควอนตัมและการคำนวณ" ผมชื่อ John Watrous และผมเป็นผู้อำนวยการด้านเทคนิค
ของ IBM Quantum Education
นี่เป็นบทเรียนที่ห้าของซีรีส์ และเป็นบทเรียนแรก
ในหน่วยที่สองของซีรีส์ ซึ่งเกี่ยวกับอัลกอริทึมควอนตัม
ในหน่วยนี้ เราจะสำรวจ
ข้อได้เปรียบทางการคำนวณของข้อมูลควอนตัม นั่นคือ เราจะดูว่าเราทำอะไรได้บ้าง
กับคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม และข้อได้เปรียบที่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมอาจมี
เหนือคอมพิวเตอร์แบบคลาสสิก
เราจะเน้นที่สิ่งที่เราทำได้ด้วยคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมเครื่องเดียว แทนที่จะเป็นสภาพแวดล้อมแบบกระจาย
เช่น
ที่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมหลายเครื่องโต้ตอบกันผ่านเครือข่ายบางประเภท
จริงๆ แล้วมีข้อได้เปรียบของควอนตัมในสภาพแวดล้อมแบบกระจาย ที่การสื่อสารและ
การเข้ารหัสลับเข้ามามีบทบาท
แต่เราจะไม่พูดถึง
เรื่องเหล่านั้นในหน่วยนี้
หน่วยนี้เกี่ยวกับอัลกอริทึมควอนตัมที่ทำงานบนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมเครื่องเดียว
เริ่มกันด้วยคำถามธรรมชาติ คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
อาจให้ข้อได้เปรียบอะไรได้บ้าง?
ข้อหลักคือ คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมอาจให้คำตอบที่เร็วกว่าสำหรับปัญหาการคำนวณบางอย่าง
เวลามีค่า และถึงแม้คอมพิวเตอร์ที่เรา
ใช้ทุกวันจะเร็วพอสมควร แต่ก็ยังช้าเกินไป
ที่จะแก้ปัญหาการคำนวณบางอย่าง เพียงเพราะความยาก
ทางการคำนวณโดยธรรมชาติของปัญหาเหล่านั้น
ศักยภาพที่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมอาจช่วยให้เราแก้ปัญหาที่คอมพิวเตอร์แบบคลาสสิก
ช้าเกินไปที่จะแก้
คือสิ่งที่ขับเคลื่อน
งานวิจัยอัลกอริทึมควอนตัมมาหลายทศวรรษ
มีทรัพยากรการคำนวณ
อื่นๆ นอกจากเวลาที่สามารถพิจารณาได้ เช่น จำนวนหน่วยความจำคอมพิวเตอร์ที่ต้องใช้สำหรับการคำนวณ
แต่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมไม่ได้
ช่วยประหยัดหน่วยความจำมากนัก ตามที่ปรากฏ และหน่วยความจำคอมพิวเตอร์แบบคลาสสิก
ก็ราคาไม่แพง
โดยเฉพาะเมื่อเทียบกับหน่วยความจำควอนตัม ดังนั้นจึงไม่มี
อะไรน่าหวังมากตรงนี้
เราอาจคิดถึงทรัพยากรอื่นๆ เช่น ปริมาณพลังงาน
ที่จำเป็นสำหรับการคำนวณ แต่จริงๆ แล้วไม่จำเป็นต้อง
ใช้พลังงานมากเลย
ในการคำนวณแบบคลาสสิก โดยเฉพาะถ้าคุณ
ยอมทำให้ช้าลง
ดังนั้นมันคือเวลา
ที่จำเป็นสำหรับการคำนวณจริงๆ นั่นคือจุดสนใจหลักของเรา
นี่คือภาพรวมของบทเรียน ซึ่งเกี่ยวกับ
โมเดลการคำนวณเฉพาะที่เรียกว่าโมเดลการสอบถาม
คุณสามารถคิดว่าโมเดลนี้เป็นเหมือนจานเพาะเชื้อสำหรับพัฒนาแนวคิดอัลกอริทึม ทั้งแบบควอนตัมและคลาสสิก
มันไม่ได้มีไว้เป็นโมเดลในทางปฏิบัติที่อธิบายปัญหา
การคำนวณประเภทที่เราเจอในชีวิตจริง
เราจะออกจากโมเดลการสอบถามในบทเรียนถัดๆ ไปของหน่วยนี้ และเน้นไปที่โมเดลที่ได้แรงบันดาลใจจากแนวคิดการคำนวณ
ที่ใช้งานได้จริงมากกว่า
แต่โมเดลการสอบถามเป็น
จุดเริ่มต้นที่ดีมาก
มันเป็นโมเดลที่เรียบง่ายที่ช่วยให้เราสำรวจ
ศักยภาพของคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม โดยไม่มีรายละเอียดทางเทคนิค
มากมายมาขวางทาง
และยังช่วยให้เราแยก
แนวคิดที่สำคัญจริงๆ เบื้องหลังการคำนวณควอนตัมและวิธีการทำงานของมันออกมาได้
การคำนวณควอนตัมเริ่มพัฒนาขึ้นจริงๆ ภายในโมเดลนี้ และแนวคิดที่
พัฒนาขึ้นภายในโมเดลนี้ได้เป็นแรงบันดาลใจโดยตรงให้กับ
อัลกอริทึมควอนตัมที่สำคัญ
เช่น อัลกอริทึมของ Shor สำหรับการแยกตัวประกอบ
ในส่วนแรกของบทเรียน เราจะดูว่าโมเดลการสอบถามของการคำนวณคืออะไรโดยเฉพาะ
และในส่วนที่สอง สาม
และสี่ เราจะพูดถึง
อัลกอริทึมการสอบถามควอนตัมสามตัว คือ อัลกอริทึมของ Deutsch
อัลกอริทึม Deutsch-Jozsa
และอัลกอริทึมของ Simon ซึ่งเผยให้เห็นข้อได้เปรียบ
ที่น่าประทับใจมากขึ้นเรื่อยๆ
ของคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
เหนือคอมพิวเตอร์แบบคลาสสิกภายในโมเดลการสอบถามของการคำนวณ
เพื่ออธิบายโมเดลการสอบถามของการคำนวณ เรามาเริ่มกันก่อนด้วยการนามธรรม
ของการคำนวณที่เป็นมาตรฐานมากกว่า
นี่คือภาพที่
แสดงการคำนวณในแง่ที่เรียบง่ายและพื้นฐานมาก
เรามีอินพุต ซึ่งมักจะอยู่ใน
รูปแบบของสตริงไบนารี แม้ว่าเราจะสามารถใช้สัญลักษณ์
อื่นๆ ได้ถ้าต้องการ
อินพุตจะถูกส่งไปยังการคำนวณ ซึ่งแสดงด้วยสี่เหลี่ยม
สีน้ำเงินในภาพนี้
และผลลัพธ์ของการคำนวณคือจะมีเอาต์พุตถูกสร้างขึ้น และอีกครั้ง โดยทั่วไปแล้ว
จะเป็นสตริงไบนารี
แน่นอน ภาพนี้
ไม่ได้ระบุเลยว่าการคำนวณนั้นทำงานอย่างไร
เราสามารถกำหนด
โมเดลการคำนวณเฉพาะต่างๆ เพื่อทำสิ่งนั้น เช่น เครื่องจักรทัวริง
และ circuit บูลีน
หรือ circuit ควอนตัม ถ้าเราคิดเกี่ยวกับ
การคำนวณควอนตัม
เป็นความจริงที่ภาพนี้
ไม่ได้แสดงข้อเท็จจริงที่ว่าคอมพิวเตอร์
ที่เราใช้ทุกวันหลายเครื่องรับ
อินพุตและผลิตเอาต์พุตอย่างต่อเนื่อง
โดยพื้นฐานแล้วคือโต้ตอบกับเราและกับคอมพิวเตอร์อื่นๆ ผ่าน
อินเทอร์เน็ต เป็นต้น
แต่เราไม่ได้พยายามแสดง
ปฏิสัมพันธ์เหล่านั้นที่นี่
นี่เป็นเรื่องเกี่ยวกับการจำลอง
งานคำนวณที่แยกออกมา
ตัวอย่างเช่น อินพุตอาจเป็น
การเข้ารหัสไบนารีของตัวเลข หรือการแสดงเมทริกซ์
หรือคำอธิบายของโมเลกุล หรืออะไรก็ตามที่เรามีในใจ และมีงานคำนวณบางอย่าง
ที่ถูกทำกับอินพุตนั้นเพียงอย่างเดียว
ประเด็นสำคัญตรงนี้คือ
อินพุตทั้งหมดถูกส่งให้การคำนวณ และไม่มีอะไร
เกี่ยวกับอินพุตที่ถูกซ่อนจากมัน
โมเดลการสอบถามของ
การคำนวณทำงานต่างออกไป
ในโมเดลการสอบถาม อินพุตจะถูกทำให้พร้อมใช้
ในรูปแบบของฟังก์ชัน ซึ่งการคำนวณสามารถ
เข้าถึงได้โดยการสอบถาม
หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือ โดยการประเมินฟังก์ชัน
กับอินพุตต่างๆ
ตรงนี้คุณจะเห็นสิ่งนั้นถูกแสดง
ในรูปแบบของภาพ
คล้ายกับที่เรามีก่อนหน้า การคำนวณถูกแสดง
ด้วยสี่เหลี่ยมสีน้ำเงิน แต่แทนที่จะรับอินพุตโดยตรง
ในรูปแบบของสตริง
ของบิต เป็นต้น มันเข้าถึงอินพุตโดยพื้นฐานแล้วคือการถามคำถาม
และรับคำตอบ
บางครั้งเราใช้
คำว่า oracle และ black box เพื่ออ้างถึงกลไก
ที่ให้อินพุต
มีความแตกต่างระหว่าง
oracle กับ black box ในทฤษฎีความซับซ้อน แต่นั่นจะไม่เกี่ยวข้องเลยสำหรับจุดประสงค์ของการสนทนานี้
อย่างไรก็ตาม คำเหล่านี้มีไว้
เพื่อสื่อแนวคิดพื้นฐาน
ในกรีซโบราณ คุณ
สามารถไปหา oracle เช่น Oracle ที่เดลฟี
และถามคำถามสำคัญ
และ oracle จะตอบ
คำถามเฉพาะนั้น แต่เธอจะไม่บอกทุกอย่างที่เธอรู้แน่นอน
ในทำนองเดียวกัน เมื่อ
เราคิดเกี่ยวกับ black box เรามีในใจ
กระบวนการหรือระบบบางอย่าง
ที่เราสามารถเลือกว่าอะไรเข้าไป และเราเห็นว่าอะไรออกมา แต่เราไม่เข้าใจ
การทำงานภายในของมัน
และนั่นคือกรณีตรงนี้ อินพุตของปัญหา
อยู่ในรูปแบบของฟังก์ชัน และสิ่งที่เราทำได้มีเพียง
การประเมินฟังก์ชันนั้น
แต่นอกเหนือจากนั้น เราไม่มี
ความรู้หรือความเข้าใจเกี่ยวกับวิธีการทำงานของมัน
ตลอดบทเรียน
เราจะใช้ตัวอักษร f สำหรับฟังก์ชันที่
แสดงอินพุต และเราจะตั้งสมมติฐาน
ว่ามันอยู่ในรูปแบบ
ที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้เสมอ
Sigma หมายถึงตัวอักษรไบนารี ดังนั้น f เป็นฟังก์ชันจากสตริง
ของบิตไปยังสตริงของบิต
และโดยเฉพาะ เรา
จะสมมติว่าอินพุตของ f เป็นสตริงของบิตที่มีความยาว n และเอาต์พุตเป็นสตริง
ของบิตที่มีความยาว m
โดยที่ n และ m เป็นจำนวนเต็มบวก
สำหรับปัญหาต่างๆ เรา
จะมีข้อจำกัดเกี่ยวกับ n และ m แต่ในทุกกรณี ฟังก์ชันอินพุตจะ
อยู่ในรูปแบบเช่นนี้
เมื่อเราบอกว่า
การคำนวณทำการสอบถาม สิ่งที่เราหมายถึงคือ
ฟังก์ชัน f ถูกประเมินหนึ่งครั้ง
นั่นคือ สตริง x บางตัวที่มีความยาว N ถูกเลือกโดยการคำนวณ และสตริง f ของ x จะ
ถูกทำให้พร้อมใช้สำหรับมัน
โดย oracle หรือ black box และสุดท้าย วิธีง่ายๆ ที่เราจะวัดต้นทุนการคำนวณ
ของอัลกอริทึมการสอบถาม คือการนับว่ามันต้องการการสอบถามกี่ครั้ง
ถึงแม้จะจริงที่
เราสนใจจริงๆ ว่าการคำนวณใช้เวลานานเท่าไหร่ เมื่อเราศึกษาโมเดลการสอบถาม
โดยทั่วไปเราจะทำให้
เรียบง่ายและแค่นับการสอบถาม และนั่นคือสิ่งที่เราจะทำในบทเรียนนี้
ทีนี้ มาดู
ตัวอย่างสักสองสามตัวของปัญหาการสอบถาม หมายถึงปัญหา
การคำนวณในโมเดลการสอบถาม
และตรงนี้ ผมจะแค่อธิบาย
ตัวปัญหาเอง และ ณ จุดนี้ ผมจะยังไม่พูดอะไร
เกี่ยวกับวิธีแก้มัน
ปัญหาแรกคือปัญหา OR
ในกรณีนี้ อินพุตเป็นฟังก์ชัน
จาก n บิตไปยังแค่ 1 บิต ดังนั้น m เท่ากับ 1 สำหรับปัญหานี้
และเอาต์พุตที่ต้องการสำหรับ
ปัญหาคือ 1 หรือ 0
ถ้ามีสตริง n บิต x บางตัวที่ f ของ x เท่ากับ 1 คำตอบที่ถูกต้องคือ 1
และมิฉะนั้น ถ้า f ของ x
เป็น 0 เสมอสำหรับทุกสตริง x คำตอบที่ถูกต้องคือ 0
ถ้าเราคิดว่าฟังก์ชัน f ให้เราเข้าถึง
สุ่มได้ไปยัง 2 ยกกำลัง n บิต หนึ่งบิตสำหรับแต่ละสตริง n บิต x
แล้วสิ่งที่มันถาม
คือ OR ของบิตเหล่านั้น และนั่นคือเหตุผลที่เรียกว่าปัญหา OR
อีกตัวอย่างหนึ่งคือปัญหาพาริตี้ ซึ่งคล้ายกับปัญหา OR ยกเว้นว่ามันถามหาพาริตี้
หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือ eXclusive OR ของค่าเอาต์พุต
แบบบิตเดียวทั้งหมดของฟังก์ชัน
อีกวิธีหนึ่งในการพูดคือ
คำตอบที่ถูกต้องคือ 0 ถ้าจำนวนสตริง n บิต x ที่ f ของ x เท่ากับ 1 เป็นจำนวนคู่
และคำตอบที่ถูกต้องคือ
1 ถ้าจำนวนนั้นเป็นจำนวนคี่
ตัวอย่างของปัญหาที่ m ไม่จำเป็นต้องเท่ากับ 1 คือปัญหาค่าต่ำสุด
ตรงนี้ ฟังก์ชัน f อยู่ในรูปแบบปกติ และไม่มีข้อจำกัดเกี่ยวกับ n และ m
และคำตอบที่ถูกต้องคือค่าเอาต์พุตใดก็ตาม
ของฟังก์ชันที่มาก่อนในการเรียงลำดับ
แบบพจนานุกรม
ของสตริงไบนารี หรืออีกทางหนึ่ง ถ้าคุณอยากจะ
คิดว่าสตริงความยาว m เป็นตัวแทนของ
จำนวนเต็มที่ไม่เป็นลบในรูปแบบไบนารี
คำตอบที่ถูกต้อง
คือค่าน้อยสุดหรือค่าต่ำสุดที่
ออกมาจากฟังก์ชันนี้
บางครั้งเราก็พิจารณาปัญหาการสอบถามที่เรามีเงื่อนไขสัญญา
กับฟังก์ชันอินพุต หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือ
การรับประกันบางอย่างเกี่ยวกับมัน
และเราไม่ต้องกังวลเกี่ยวกับฟังก์ชันที่ไม่เป็นไปตามเงื่อนไขสัญญานั้น
ฟังก์ชันที่ไม่เป็นไปตามเงื่อนไขสัญญาถือว่าเป็นอินพุตแบบ "ไม่สนใจ"
และเราไม่ต้องรับผิดชอบสิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นกับอินพุตเหล่านั้น
นี่คือตัวอย่างของปัญหาการสอบถามที่มีเงื่อนไขสัญญา เรียกว่าการค้นหาแบบเฉพาะ
มันเกี่ยวข้องกับปัญหา OR
แต่มันต่างกัน
ฟังก์ชันอินพุตมีรูปแบบเดียวกัน
กับปัญหา OR นั่นคือมันแปลง
สตริง n บิตไปเป็นบิต
คราวนี้ เรามีเงื่อนไขสัญญาว่า
มีสตริง Z เพียงตัวเดียวที่ทำให้ f ประเมินได้เป็น 1
โดยที่ f ของ x เท่ากับ 0
สำหรับทุกสตริง x นอกจาก z และเอาต์พุตที่ถูกต้อง
คือสตริง z ที่ไม่ซ้ำนี้
แน่นอนว่ามี
ตัวเลือกสำหรับฟังก์ชัน f ที่ไม่เป็นไปตามเงื่อนไขนี้ แต่เราไม่ได้วางข้อกำหนดใดๆ เลย
ต่ออัลกอริทึมสำหรับปัญหานี้ เมื่อมันได้รับ
ฟังก์ชันแบบนั้นเป็นอินพุต
เราสนใจเฉพาะฟังก์ชันที่เป็นไปตามเงื่อนไขสัญญาเท่านั้น
ทีนี้ ปัญหาทั้งสี่อย่าง
ที่ผมเพิ่งพูดถึงเป็นปัญหาที่ค่อนข้างเป็นธรรมชาติ หมายความว่ามันง่ายที่จะอธิบาย
และง่ายที่จะจินตนาการสถานการณ์ที่ความจำเป็นในการแก้มันอาจเกิดขึ้น แต่ปัญหาการสอบถามบางอย่าง
ไม่ได้เป็นแบบนี้เลย
จริงๆ แล้ว บางครั้งเราพิจารณา
ปัญหาการสอบถามที่ถูกสร้างขึ้นมาอย่างมาก ที่มันยากจะจินตนาการว่าจะมีใคร
อยากแก้มันจริงๆ
ปัญหาของ Simon ซึ่งเรา
จะเห็นทีหลังในบทเรียน ก็ค่อนข้างจะเข้าหมวดนี้ แต่มีปัญหาอื่นๆ อีก
ที่แย่กว่ามากในแง่หนึ่ง แต่พวกมันก็กลับกลายเป็นสำคัญมากต่อการศึกษาโมเดลการสอบถาม
เราไม่ได้ศึกษาปัญหาเหล่านี้เพราะเราจำเป็นต้อง
แก้มันในทางปฏิบัติ
วิธีที่คุณคิดเกี่ยวกับมันได้คือ เรากำลังมองหา
สิ่งสุดขั้วประเภทต่างๆ
โดยเฉพาะ เมื่อเราทำงานภายใน
จานเพาะเชื้อของโมเดลนี้ วิธีที่เป็นธรรมชาติในการสำรวจ
แนวคิดอัลกอริทึมควอนตัม
คือการกำหนดปัญหาที่ถูกสร้างขึ้นมาอย่างมาก ที่เราสามารถใช้ประโยชน์จาก
พลังของคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมได้ดีที่สุด
และสิ่งนี้สามารถ
ให้แสงสว่างอย่างมากเกี่ยวกับวิธีที่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
อาจมีประโยชน์ในสถานการณ์ที่ใช้งานได้จริงมากกว่า
เราสามารถทำให้แนวคิด
ของการสอบถามเป็นทางการได้หลายวิธี ขึ้นอยู่กับว่าเรา
ทำงานกับโมเดลการคำนวณแบบใด
ตัวอย่างเช่น ในโมเดล
เครื่องจักรทัวริงของการคำนวณ ซึ่งเราไม่ได้พูดถึง และเราจะไม่ลงลึกในซีรีส์นี้
มีวิธีหนึ่งในการ
ทำให้แนวคิดของการสอบถามเป็นทางการ ที่สมเหตุสมผลสำหรับโมเดลนั้น
สำหรับโมเดล circuit เรานิยาม gate ชนิดพิเศษ
ที่เรียกว่า query gate และนั่นคือวิธีที่การสอบถาม
ถูกแสดงอย่างเป็นทางการ
สำหรับ circuit บูลีน มีวิธีง่ายๆ มากในการทำสิ่งนี้ ซึ่งก็แค่จินตนาการ
ว่าเรามี query gate
ที่ประเมินฟังก์ชันอินพุตโดยตรง อย่างที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้บนหน้าจอ
แนวคิดคือเราสามารถ
ใช้ query gate เหล่านี้สร้าง circuit ที่แก้ปัญหา
อะไรก็ตามที่เรากำลังดูอยู่
และเพื่อให้ทำงานได้ถูกต้อง circuit ต้องให้คำตอบที่ถูกสำหรับฟังก์ชันอินพุต f ใดก็ตามที่ได้รับ
โดยสมมติว่ามันเป็นไปตามเงื่อนไขสัญญา ในกรณีของปัญหาที่มีเงื่อนไขสัญญา
นี่คือตัวอย่างง่ายๆ
ของ circuit บูลีนที่แก้ปัญหา
พาริตี้เมื่อ n เท่ากับ 1
ดังนั้นฟังก์ชันอินพุต f เป็นฟังก์ชันจาก
1 บิตไป 1 บิตในกรณีนี้
สิ่งที่ circuit นี้ทำคือประเมินฟังก์ชัน
f บนอินพุต 0 และ 1 โดยใช้ query gate สองตัวนี้
จากนั้นก็เสียบค่าเอาต์พุตสองค่าที่
ได้จาก query gate เข้าไปใน circuit บูลีนจากบทเรียนที่สามที่คำนวณ XOR
ซึ่งเป็นสิ่งเดียวกับพาริตี้
ให้ชัดเจน ค่าอินพุต
สองค่าตรงนี้ไม่ใช่อินพุตของปัญหา
หมายถึงปัญหาพาริตี้
เมื่อเราทำงานกับโมเดลการสอบถาม อินพุตของปัญหา
คือฟังก์ชัน f และคุณควรคิดว่า
อินพุตสองตัวนี้เข้า circuit
เป็นค่าที่ถูกกำหนดตายตัว
ที่ไม่เคยเปลี่ยน พวกมันเป็นส่วนหนึ่งของอัลกอริทึมโดยพื้นฐาน
เราต้องการคำนวณ XOR ของ f 0 และ f 1 ดังนั้นเราจึงกำหนดค่าเริ่มต้น
สายสองเส้นนี้แบบนี้
เพื่อให้มันทำงานได้ เราใช้ query gate สองตัว
ตรงนี้ ตัวนี้กับตัวนี้
ดังนั้นอัลกอริทึมที่แสดงโดย
circuit บูลีนนี้ทำการสอบถามสองครั้ง และถ้าเราคิดเกี่ยวกับ
ปัญหาพาริตี้สักครู่
สำหรับฟังก์ชันจากหนึ่งบิตไปหนึ่งบิต เราจะเห็นว่าจำเป็นอย่างยิ่งที่ circuit บูลีนใดก็ตาม
ที่แก้ปัญหานี้
ต้องทำการสอบถามอย่างน้อยสองครั้ง
ถ้าคุณทำการสอบถามแค่ครั้งเดียว ดังนั้นคุณรู้แค่ค่าเอาต์พุต
เดียวของฟังก์ชัน f ไม่ใช่อีกค่า คุณจะไม่มี
ข้อมูลอะไรเลย
เกี่ยวกับพาริตี้ เพราะค่าเอาต์พุตอีกค่า
อาจเป็น 0 หรือ 1 ก็ได้ ซึ่งนำไปสู่
คำตอบที่เป็นไปได้ทั้งสอง
ของปัญหา ดังนั้นในแง่ของจำนวน
การสอบถามที่มันทำ circuit บูลีนนี้ดีที่สุดเท่าที่จะเป็นไปได้
สำหรับปัญหาพาริตี้
เมื่อ n เท่ากับ 1
มีอีกประเด็นหนึ่งเกี่ยวกับ query gate ที่ควรพูดถึงก่อนที่เราจะไปต่อ นั่นคือเมื่อเราออกแบบและวิเคราะห์อัลกอริทึมการสอบถาม
เราไม่ต้องกังวลเลยว่า
query gate จะถูกสร้างอย่างไร
สมมติว่า
query gate เหล่านี้ถูกให้มา และความยากในการสร้าง
มันไม่ใช่เรื่องของเรา
คุณสามารถคิดว่า
query gate เองเป็นอินพุตก็ได้ถ้าอยาก และมันไม่ใช่หน้าที่ของเราที่จะสร้างอินพุต เราแค่พยายาม
แก้ปัญหาเฉพาะ
เมื่อได้รับอินพุต แน่นอนว่าเมื่อ f เป็นฟังก์ชัน
จากหนึ่งบิตไปหนึ่งบิต มีตัวเลือกที่เป็นไปได้แค่สี่ตัว
และมันก็ง่ายพอ
ที่จะสร้างตัวใดตัวหนึ่งก็ได้ แต่โดยทั่วไป สำหรับฟังก์ชัน
ที่มีบิตอินพุตมากๆ
มันอาจยากมากที่จะสร้าง query gate
สำหรับฟังก์ชันเหล่านั้น
ให้ชัดเจน นี่ไม่ใช่
การบอกว่าเรื่องของวิธีสร้าง query gate
ไม่สำคัญ แต่ว่ามันไม่ถูกพิจารณา
เป็นส่วนหนึ่งของต้นทุน
ของอัลกอริทึมการสอบถาม
สิ่งนี้สอดคล้องกับแนวคิดที่ว่านี่ไม่ได้เกี่ยวกับ
การคำนวณในทางปฏิบัติหรือการสร้าง circuit จริงๆ
มันเกี่ยวกับการทำงานภายใน
กรอบทฤษฎีที่บอกเราเรื่อง
น่าสนใจเกี่ยวกับการคำนวณ
เราจะมีอะไรพูดเพิ่มเกี่ยวกับเรื่องนี้ เมื่อเราก้าวกระโดดจากโมเดลนี้ไปสู่โมเดลการคำนวณที่เป็นมาตรฐานมากกว่า และนั่นคือสิ่งหลักที่บทเรียนถัดไป
บทเรียนที่ 6 จะพูดถึง
ทีนี้ มาหันความสนใจ
ของเราไปที่ circuit ควอนตัม
สำหรับ circuit ควอนตัม เราจะเปลี่ยน
นิยามของ query gate ให้เป็นแบบยูนิทารี
เราต้องการจะสามารถทำ
การสอบถามภายใน circuit ควอนตัมและให้มันทำงาน
แบบเชิงเส้นกับสถานะควอนตัม
เพื่อที่เราจะสามารถ
ทำการสอบถามในซูเปอร์โพซิชันได้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ
อาจดูเหมือนเราขยับเสาประตู
โดยเปลี่ยนความหมายของการสอบถาม เมื่อเทียบกับสิ่งที่เราเพิ่ง
เห็นสำหรับ circuit บูลีน
แต่มีเหตุผลรองรับ ซึ่งเราจะพูดถึงรายละเอียดเพิ่มเติม
ในบทเรียนถัดไป
ตอนนี้ มันแค่เป็นนิยาม
โดยเฉพาะ
นิยามเป็นดังนี้ เมื่อกำหนดฟังก์ชัน f
ในรูปแบบเดียวกับก่อนหน้า
หมายความว่ามันแปลงสตริง n บิต
ไปเป็นสตริง m บิต query gate Uf ทำงานบน n + m qubit
และถูกนิยามโดย
การกระทำที่อธิบายตรงนี้บนสถานะฐานมาตรฐาน
เราจะเห็นรูป
ที่แสดงนิยามนี้ในอีกสักครู่ แต่ก่อนอื่น ให้ผมอธิบายสัญกรณ์
ที่ใช้ตรงนี้ให้ชัดเจน
และนั่นคือเมื่อใดก็ตามที่เรา
ใช้สัญลักษณ์ของ XOR เป็นการดำเนินการระหว่างสตริง
สองตัวที่มีความยาวเท่ากัน
เราหมายถึง
eXclusive OR แบบทีละบิต และตรงนี้คุณเห็นตัวอย่าง
ในนิยาม เรามีว่าทั้ง y และ f ของ
x เป็นสตริงความยาว m ดังนั้นสตริงตรงนี้
แสดงสตริงที่เราได้
โดยการ XOR สตริงสองตัวนั้น
เข้าด้วยกัน ทีละบิต และนี่คือแผนภาพ
ที่อธิบายว่า gate เหล่านี้ทำงานอย่างไร
n qubit บนสุดตรงกับ
อาร์กิวเมนต์ของฟังก์ชัน
และเมื่อมันเริ่มต้น
ในสถานะฐานมาตรฐาน cat x ในแผนภาพนี้ สถานะฐานมาตรฐานนั้น
ผ่านไปโดยไม่เปลี่ยนแปลง
และถูกสะท้อนออกมาเป็นส่วนหนึ่งของเอาต์พุต
m qubit ล่างสุดตรงกับเอาต์พุต
ของฟังก์ชัน f และเมื่อมันเริ่มต้นใน
สถานะฐานมาตรฐานใดก็ตาม
cat y ในแผนภาพนี้ สิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นคือ
เอาต์พุตของฟังก์ชัน f ของ x ถูก XOR ลงบนสตริง y
นี่คือสิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นสำหรับ
สถานะฐานมาตรฐาน และถ้าเราอยากรู้ว่า
สิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นโดยทั่วไปสำหรับสถานะควอนตัมอื่นๆ เรา
ใช้ความเป็นเชิงเส้น เหมือนที่เราทำเสมอ
เหตุผลที่นิยาม query gate แบบนี้ ที่เราสะท้อนอินพุตออกมา และเราใช้ XOR แบบทีละบิตสำหรับเอาต์พุต
คือ gate เหล่านี้เป็นยูนิทารีเสมอ สำหรับทุกตัวเลือกของฟังก์ชัน f
นี่คือการดำเนินการ
แบบกำหนดได้จริงๆ
และถ้าเราแสดงมันเป็นเมทริกซ์ สำหรับทุกตัวเลือกของฟังก์ชัน F เราจะได้เมทริกซ์เรียงสับเปลี่ยน
หมายถึงเมทริกซ์ที่มีค่าหนึ่งเดียวในแต่ละแถวและแต่ละคอลัมน์ และรายการอื่นทั้งหมดเท่ากับ 0
และเมทริกซ์เรียงสับเปลี่ยน
เป็นยูนิทารีเสมอ
จริงๆ แล้ว สำหรับการดำเนินการนี้ เราจะได้ว่าการดำเนินการ
เป็นอินเวอร์สของตัวเอง ดังนั้น Uf แดกเกอร์เท่ากับ Uf
ถ้าสิ่งที่เราต้องการทำกับ gate
เหล่านี้คือประเมิน f ของ x สำหรับสตริง x บางตัว มันง่าย
เราแค่ตั้ง y เป็น
สตริงที่เป็นศูนย์ทั้งหมด ดังนั้นเมื่อเราทำ eXclusive OR ของบิต y เราจะได้แค่ f ของ x
ตรงนี้ คุณจะเห็นสัญกรณ์ที่ใช้แทนสตริงที่เป็นศูนย์ทั้งหมด
มันดูเหมือน 0 ยกกำลัง M แต่ไม่ใช่ความหมายนั้น
มันหมายถึงสตริงของศูนย์
ที่มีความยาวเท่ากับ M
เมื่อเราพูดถึง
สตริงแทนที่จะเป็นตัวเลข เลขยกกำลังมักหมายความว่าเราทำซ้ำสตริงนั้น
จำนวนหนึ่งครั้ง
ดังนั้นนี่คือ 0 ซ้ำ m ครั้ง
มันเป็นแค่วิธีที่สะดวกและแม่นยำในการอธิบายสตริงนี้
อีกครั้ง เมื่อเรา
ทำงานกับโมเดลการสอบถาม เราไม่ได้กังวลว่าจะ
สร้าง query gate เหล่านี้อย่างไร
นั่นเป็นปัญหาเดียวกัน
ที่เรามีกับ query gate สำหรับ circuit บูลีน
มันไม่ใช่หน้าที่ของเราที่จะเตรียมอินพุต เราได้รับอินพุตใน
รูปแบบของ query gate เหล่านี้
แต่ผมจะชี้ให้เห็นว่า ถ้าเรารู้วิธี
สร้างฟังก์ชัน f โดยใช้ circuit บูลีน มันเป็นไปได้ที่จะ
แปลงการสร้างนั้น
ค่อนข้างตรงๆ ไปเป็น circuit ควอนตัม
ที่สร้าง Uf และเราจะเห็นว่า
มันทำงานอย่างไรในบทเรียนถัดไป
เป็นเรื่องนอกเรื่อง มันค่อนข้างตรงไปตรงมาที่จะสร้าง circuit บูลีน
ที่ทำงานแบบนี้ โดยใช้
query gate คลาสสิกตัวเดียวสำหรับฟังก์ชัน f
แต่นั่นค่อนข้างแตกต่างจากการมี circuit ควอนตัม
ที่สร้าง gate ยูนิทารีนี้
ประเด็นก็คือ
สำหรับอัลกอริทึมการสอบถามแบบคลาสสิก การมี query gate ที่ทำงานแบบนี้ ที่จริงแล้วเทียบเท่า
กับการมี
query gate คลาสสิกธรรมดาสำหรับ f ในแง่ที่ว่าตัวใดตัวหนึ่งสามารถสร้างได้โดยใช้อีกตัว
ในส่วนนี้ของบทเรียน เราจะพูดถึงอัลกอริทึมของ Deutsch ซึ่งเป็น
อัลกอริทึมการสอบถามควอนตัมที่ง่ายมาก แต่มันเป็นอัญมณีจริงๆ
อัลกอริทึมนี้มาจากบทความปี 1985 ที่เขียนโดย David Deutsch ซึ่งเป็นหนึ่งในคนแรกๆ ที่ทำงานเกี่ยวกับรากฐาน
ทางทฤษฎีของการคำนวณควอนตัม
ตัวอัลกอริทึมเองเป็นส่วนเล็กมาก
ของบทความปี 1985 ของ Deutsch และจริงๆ แล้ว
อัลกอริทึมที่เราเรียกว่า
อัลกอริทึมของ Deutsch ตอนนี้ จริงๆ เป็นเวอร์ชันที่ปรับปรุงแล้วของอัลกอริทึมที่ Deutsch อธิบายไว้
มันให้ตัวอย่างเล็กๆ น้อยๆ ของวิธีที่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมสามารถ
ให้ข้อได้เปรียบทางการคำนวณ แต่คุณต้องเริ่มจากที่ไหนสักที่
และมันเป็นประกายไฟสำคัญจริงๆ ที่ทำให้สิ่งต่างๆ เริ่มต้นขึ้น
อัลกอริทึมของ Deutsch แก้ปัญหาการสอบถามที่มักเรียกว่าปัญหาของ Deutsch ในบริบทของการคำนวณควอนตัม
แต่จริงๆ แล้ว มันไม่ใช่อะไรอื่น
นอกจากปัญหาพาริตี้สำหรับฟังก์ชันจากหนึ่งบิตไปหนึ่งบิต ซึ่งเราได้พูดถึงไปแล้ว
อย่างที่เราเห็นแล้ว มีฟังก์ชันสี่ตัว
จากหนึ่งบิตไปหนึ่งบิต และมันถูกอธิบายตรงนี้บนหน้าจอโดยตารางค่า
ฟังก์ชันแรกและสุดท้าย
เป็นค่าคงที่ ในขณะที่สองตัวตรงกลางเป็นแบบสมดุล ในแง่ที่ว่าค่าเอาต์พุต
ที่เป็นไปได้สองค่า
ปรากฏจำนวนครั้งเท่ากัน
สำหรับฟังก์ชันค่าคงที่สองตัว
เราเห็นว่าพาริตี้ หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือ eXclusive OR ของเอาต์พุตสองค่าเป็น 0
และสำหรับฟังก์ชันสมดุลสองตัว พาริตี้ของเอาต์พุตคือ 1
ดังนั้นวิธีอื่นในการ
อธิบายปัญหาพาริตี้ในกรณีเฉพาะนี้ ที่ฟังก์ชัน f รับ
บิตเดียวเป็นอินพุต
หรือพูดอีกอย่าง ปัญหาของ Deutsch ก็คือที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้
อินพุตเป็นฟังก์ชัน f
จากหนึ่งบิตไปหนึ่งบิต และเอาต์พุตคือ 0 ถ้า f เป็นค่าคงที่
และ 1 ถ้า f เป็นแบบสมดุล
อย่างที่ผมบอกไปแล้ว อัลกอริทึมการสอบถามแบบคลาสสิกทุกตัว
ที่แก้ปัญหานี้ต้องทำการสอบถาม f อย่างน้อยสองครั้ง
ถ้าคุณเรียนรู้แค่ค่า
เอาต์พุตค่าเดียวจากสองค่าของ f คุณยังไม่มีข้อมูลอะไรเลยเกี่ยวกับพาริตี้ของเอาต์พุตทั้งสอง
และนี่ จริงๆ แล้ว
เป็นจริงแม้แต่สำหรับอัลกอริทึมแบบคลาสสิกที่ใช้ความสุ่ม
ความสุ่มบางครั้งมีประโยชน์มากสำหรับการแก้ปัญหาการสอบถาม และเราจะเห็นตัวอย่าง
ทีหลังในบทเรียน
แต่ความสุ่มไม่ช่วยตรงนี้
ดังนั้นอัลกอริทึมของเราจากก่อนหน้านี้เป็นอัลกอริทึมที่ดีที่สุดในบรรดาอัลกอริทึมการสอบถามแบบคลาสสิก
สำหรับปัญหาของ Deutsch
ทีนี้เรามาดู
อัลกอริทึมของ Deutsch ซึ่งเป็นอัลกอริทึมการสอบถามควอนตัมที่แก้ปัญหาของ Deutsch
โดยใช้การสอบถามเพียงครั้งเดียว
และนี่คืออัลกอริทึม
ที่อธิบายเป็น circuit ควอนตัม
เรามี qubit สองตัว
ที่ถูกกำหนดค่าเริ่มต้นตามที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้ ตัวบนถูกกำหนดค่าเริ่มต้นเป็น cat 0 และตัวล่างถูกกำหนดค่าเริ่มต้นเป็น cat 1
และเราจะเห็นว่าทำไมเราถึงกำหนดค่าเริ่มต้น qubit เหล่านี้แบบนี้ในไม่ช้า
เราทำ Hadamard
gate บน qubit สองตัว ป้อนเข้า query gate ทำ Hadamard
gate อีกตัวบน qubit บน
แล้วก็วัดมัน และข้อกล่าวอ้างคือ
ผลลัพธ์การวัดให้เรา อย่างแน่นอน
คำตอบที่ถูกต้องของปัญหา
มาวิเคราะห์
circuit ทีละขั้นตอนเพื่อดูว่ามันทำงานอย่างไรกันเถอะ
สถานะของ qubit สองตัวหลังจากชั้นแรกของ Hadamard gate คือเทนเซอร์โปรดักต์ของ
สถานะลบและสถานะบวก
Hadamard ตัวบนแปลง
สถานะ 0 เป็นสถานะบวก และ Hadamard ตัวล่างแปลงสถานะ 1 เป็นสถานะลบ
qubit บนอยู่ทางขวา และ qubit ล่างอยู่ทางซ้าย ดังนั้นนี่คือสถานะที่เราได้
สำคัญมากที่ qubit ล่างอยู่ในสถานะลบ สิ่งนี้จะไม่ทำงานถ้าเรา
กำหนดค่าเริ่มต้น qubit ล่าง
เป็นสถานะ 0 แทนที่จะเป็นสถานะ 1
เราจะขยายสถานะนี้
บางส่วน อย่างที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้
เหตุผลในการทำแบบนั้น
ไม่ชัดเจน ณ จุดนี้ แต่มันจะสะดวก
ในอีกสักครู่
ต่อไป มาคิดเกี่ยวกับ
สถานะของ qubit สองตัวหลังจากที่ query gate ถูกทำ
วิธีที่ query gate
ทำงานคือมันคำนวณ F บนสถานะฐานมาตรฐาน
ของ qubit บน และ XOR ค่า
ลงบน qubit ล่าง
และตรงนี้เราเห็น
ผลลัพธ์ของการทำแบบนั้น
สำหรับพจน์แรก สถานะฐานมาตรฐาน
ของ qubit บนคือ 0 ดังนั้น f ของศูนย์จะถูก XOR
ลงบน qubit ล่าง
และนั่นทำงานโดยความเป็นเชิงเส้น และมันคล้ายกันสำหรับพจน์ที่สอง ยกเว้นว่าสถานะฐานมาตรฐาน
สำหรับ qubit บนคือ 1 ดังนั้นเรา XOR f ของ 1 ลงบน qubit ล่าง
และ ณ จุดนี้ เราสามารถ
ทำให้นิพจน์นี้ง่ายขึ้นโดยสังเกตสูตร
ที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้ข้างล่าง ซึ่งทำงานเมื่อ a เป็น 0 หรือ 1
และเราสามารถตรวจสอบสิ่งนี้สำหรับค่าสองค่านั้นแยกกัน
ถ้า a เท่ากับ 0 การ
XOR ด้วย a ไม่ทำอะไรเลย และลบ 1 ยกกำลัง 0 คือ 1
ดังนั้นสองข้างเท่ากัน และถ้า a เท่ากับ 1 เราได้ cat 1 ลบ cat
0 เมื่อเราทำ XOR
ซึ่งคือลบ 1
คูณ cat 0 ลบ cat 1
และถ้าเราใช้สูตรนั้น
เพื่อทำให้สถานะง่ายขึ้น โดยที่เราตั้ง a เท่ากับ
f ของ 0 ทางซ้าย และ a เท่ากับ f ของ 1 ทางขวา
เราได้นิพจน์
ที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้
เมื่อเราเปรียบเทียบ
เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมสองตัว π1 กับ π2 เราเห็นว่าสิ่งที่ gate Uf ทำ
คือใส่ค่าหนึ่ง
ในสองค่า f ของ 0 หรือ f ของ 1 เข้าไปใน
เลขยกกำลังของลบ 1 อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ
หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือ เข้าไปใน
เฟสของแต่ละพจน์
นี่คือเหตุผลสำหรับ
การกำหนดค่าเริ่มต้น qubit ล่างเป็น 1 และทำ Hadamard gate บนมันเพื่อสร้างสถานะลบ
ซึ่งทำให้สิ่งนี้เกิดขึ้นได้
เรียกว่าปรากฏการณ์เฟสคิกแบ็ค และเราจะกลับมาดูมันอีกครั้งในอีกสักครู่
มันค่อนข้างสำคัญ และเราจะเห็นมันเกิดขึ้น
อีกสองสามครั้งในบทเรียน รวมถึงในบทเรียนต่อๆ ไป
ตอนนี้เราสามารถทำให้ง่ายขึ้นโดยดึง
สถานะลบกลับออกมาข้างนอก เพื่อให้ได้นิพจน์
ที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้
เป็นเรื่องนอกเรื่อง มัน
น่าสนใจที่จะสังเกตว่าจริงๆ แล้วไม่มี
ความพัวพัน (entanglement) ตรงนี้เลย
สถานะทั้งสองเป็นสถานะผลคูณ ดังนั้น ความพัวพัน
น่าสนใจมากก็จริง
แต่ไม่ได้
มีบทบาทอะไรเลยในอัลกอริทึมนี้โดยเฉพาะ
มาจัดระเบียบนิดหน่อยเพื่อให้เรามีพื้นที่มากขึ้น
สิ่งที่เราทำได้ตอนนี้คือ
ดึงตัวคูณลบ 1 ยกกำลัง f ของศูนย์ออกมาข้างนอก
เพื่อให้ได้นิพจน์ของ
สถานะที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้
คุณจะสังเกตว่าตรงนี้ เรามี eXclusive OR ของ f 0 และ f 1 อยู่ในเลขยกกำลังของลบ 1
เราอาจคาดว่ามันจะ
เป็น f ของ 1 ลบ f ของ 0 เพราะเราดึงตัวคูณลบ 1 ยกกำลัง f ของ 0 ออกมา
แต่เราได้ค่าเดียวกัน
ถ้าเราทำ XOR เพราะว่าเหล่านี้เป็นบิต และสิ่งเดียวที่สำคัญเมื่อเรามีจำนวนเต็มใน
เลขยกกำลังของลบ 1
คือจำนวนเต็มนั้นเป็นคู่หรือคี่
อีกวิธีหนึ่งในการแสดง
สถานะนี้คืออย่างที่เรามีตรงนี้ ที่เราแค่พิจารณา
สองกรณีที่เป็นไปได้ของ XOR
และนั่นเป็นวิธีที่สะดวก
ในการแสดงสถานะ เมื่อเราพิจารณาการกระทำ
ของ Hadamard gate สุดท้ายร่วมกับการวัด
เมื่อเราทำ Hadamard
gate สุดท้ายบน qubit บน สถานะบวกจะ
ถูกแปลงเป็นสถานะ 0
และสถานะลบจะ
ถูกแปลงเป็นสถานะ 1 ซึ่งเราสามารถเขียน
อย่างกระชับมากขึ้นแบบนี้
และสุดท้าย เมื่อ
การวัดถูกทำ ผลลัพธ์ที่เราได้จึงเป็น
XOR ของ f 0 และ f 1
ซึ่งเป็นค่าที่เรากำลังมองหา และนั่นคือวิธีที่อัลกอริทึมของ Deutsch ทำงาน
มันค่อนข้างง่าย และถ้าเราถามตัวเองว่า
อะไรที่ทำให้มันทำงาน ที่ช่วยให้เราคำนวณ
พาริตี้ของสองบิต
ด้วยการสอบถามเพียงครั้งเดียวแทนที่จะเป็นสองครั้ง คำตอบที่สมเหตุสมผลคือ
มันคือการแทรกสอด
เรากำลัง
คำนวณ f ของ 0 และ f ของ 1 พร้อมกันอย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ เพราะเราทำ
Hadamard gate ก่อน
บน qubit บนเพื่อใส่อินพุตของ f เข้าไปใน
ซูเปอร์โพซิชันของ 0 และ 1
และโดยอาศัยเฟสคิกแบ็คร่วมกับ Hadamard gate สุดท้าย เราสร้าง
การแทรกสอดแบบเสริมกัน
สำหรับคำตอบที่ถูก และการแทรกสอดแบบหักล้าง
สำหรับคำตอบที่ผิด
ดังนั้นเราไม่เห็นคำตอบที่ผิด เราเห็นแค่คำตอบที่ถูก
ให้ผมพูดเพิ่มเติมอีกนิดเกี่ยวกับปรากฏการณ์เฟสคิกแบ็ค เพื่อดูมันจาก
มุมที่ต่างออกไปเล็กน้อย
ก่อนอื่น มาสังเกต
สูตรง่ายๆ นี้ที่ b และ c เป็นค่าไบนารีใดๆ ก็ได้
โดยสรุป การ XOR บิต b ด้วยค่า 1 เป็นสิ่งเดียวกับการทำ NOT gate หรือการดำเนินการ x บน b
และแน่นอนว่าการ XOR
บิต b ด้วยค่า 0 ไม่ทำอะไรกับมัน ซึ่งเป็นสิ่งเดียวกับการทำ
การดำเนินการเอกลักษณ์บนมัน
และเราสามารถแสดงการดำเนินการเอกลักษณ์เป็น x ยกกำลัง 0
ถ้าเราทำ Uf gate บน qubit สองตัวในสถานะฐานมาตรฐาน
cat b เทนเซอร์ cat a
เราได้ผลลัพธ์นี้ แค่จากนิยามของ Uf gate
และโดยใช้สูตร เราสามารถเขียนสถานะนั้นอีกแบบหนึ่งตามที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้
สูตรนี้ใช้ได้สำหรับทุกตัวเลือกของ b ดังนั้นโดยความเป็นเชิงเส้น มันใช้ได้
สำหรับสถานะ SI ใดๆ ก็ได้
แทนที่ cat b
และโดยเฉพาะ ถ้าเราต้องการ เราสามารถเลือก SI เป็นสถานะลบ
และนี่คือกุญแจว่าทำไมปรากฏการณ์
เฟสคิกแบ็คถึงเกิดขึ้น
มันเป็นเพราะการดำเนินการ x
ที่ทำกับสถานะลบให้ลบ 1 คูณสถานะลบ
ในทางคณิตศาสตร์ เราบอกว่าสถานะ
ลบเป็น eigenvector ของการดำเนินการ x โดยมี eigen value เท่ากับลบ 1
Eigenvector และ eigen value
สำคัญมากในพีชคณิตเชิงเส้น รวมถึง
ในข้อมูลควอนตัม และเราจะมีอะไรพูด
อีกมากเกี่ยวกับมัน
เมื่อซีรีส์ดำเนินต่อไป
แต่ตอนนี้ สิ่งที่เราต้องการ
มีแค่สูตรง่ายๆ นี้
และใช้มัน เราสามารถ
ทำให้เวกเตอร์สถานะง่ายขึ้น
และนั่นคือปรากฏการณ์เฟส
คิกแบ็คที่เขียนเป็นสูตร
มันทำงานเพราะสถานะ
ลบเป็น eigenvector ของการดำเนินการ NOT ที่มี
eigen value เป็นลบหนึ่ง
เราจะขยายสิ่งนี้
อย่างมากในบทเรียนที่ 7 เมื่อเราหันไปดูขั้นตอน
การประมาณเฟส ซึ่งเป็นสิ่งที่ขับเคลื่อน
อัลกอริทึมแยกตัวประกอบของ Shor
เราสามารถเห็นสูตรนี้ในการวิเคราะห์อัลกอริทึมของ Deutsch
ได้ดังนี้
ก่อน query gate สถานะของเราคือเทนเซอร์โปรดักต์ของสถานะลบและสถานะบวก
จากนั้นเราทำ query gate และขยาย
สถานะบวกจะให้สถานะนี้
ตอนนี้เราใช้สูตรเฟสคิกแบ็คเพื่อให้ได้นิพจน์นี้ แล้วการวิเคราะห์
ก็ดำเนินต่อเหมือนเดิม
มันเหมือนเดิม แต่ตรงนี้เราแค่เน้นที่
เฟสคิกแบ็คเพื่อให้เราจำมันได้
และเราก็พร้อมสำหรับ
มันเมื่อมันปรากฏขึ้นอีก
ต่อไปเราจะหันไปดู
อัลกอริทึม Deutsch-Jozsa ซึ่งเป็นส่วนขยาย
ของอัลกอริทึมของ Deutsch ที่แก้ปัญหา
การสอบถามได้สองสามปัญหา
ข้อได้เปรียบที่
อัลกอริทึมของ Deutsch ให้เหนืออัลกอริทึมแบบคลาสสิก
ค่อนข้างเล็กน้อย สอบถามครั้งเดียวเทียบกับสองครั้ง
อัลกอริทึม Deutsch-Jozsa เพิ่มข้อได้เปรียบนั้นขึ้นบ้าง และผมจะอธิบายว่าหมายความว่าอะไร
เมื่อเราไปถึงตรงนั้น
อัลกอริทึม Deutsch-Jozsa สามารถมองได้ว่าเป็นวิธีที่เป็นธรรมชาติและตรงไปตรงมาในการขยายอัลกอริทึมของ Deutsch
จากฟังก์ชันจากหนึ่งบิตไปหนึ่งบิต เป็นฟังก์ชันจาก n บิตไปหนึ่งบิต หรือพูดอีกอย่าง ฟังก์ชันในรูปแบบนี้
เป็น circuit ควอนตัม อัลกอริทึม Deutsch-Jozsa
ดูเป็นแบบนี้ และผมจะเรียก circuit นี้ว่า
circuit Deutsch-Jozsa
เพื่อแยกความแตกต่างเล็กน้อย
ระหว่าง circuit นี้กับตัวอัลกอริทึม Deutsch-Jozsa เอง เพราะยังมี
ขั้นตอนการประมวลผลภายหลังแบบคลาสสิกด้วย
แนวคิดคือถ้าเรารัน
circuit นี้แล้ววัด เราจะได้สตริง n บิต y บางตัว
ที่บอกเราบางอย่าง
เกี่ยวกับฟังก์ชัน f
ตรงนี้ ผมยังไม่ได้บอกจริงๆ
ว่าปัญหาการสอบถามคืออะไรที่เราอาจหวังจะ
แก้ด้วย circuit นี้ นั่นจะมาเร็วๆ นี้
แต่ประเด็นคือ
โดยการรัน circuit นี้ เราจะได้ข้อมูลบางอย่างเกี่ยวกับ f ที่อาจช่วย
เราแก้ปัญหาการสอบถาม
ที่ f เป็นอินพุต และอย่างที่ผมบอกเมื่อกี้ เราสามารถใช้ circuit นี้
เพื่อแก้ปัญหาการสอบถาม
ได้สองสามปัญหา
ก่อนอื่น มาดู
ปัญหาการสอบถามที่เรียกว่าปัญหา Deutsch-Jozsa ซึ่งเป็นปัญหาที่
circuit Deutsch-Jozsa
ถูกออกแบบมาเพื่อแก้ตั้งแต่แรก
ปัญหา Deutsch-Jozsa เป็นการขยายของปัญหาของ Deutsch ที่เป้าหมายคือการระบุว่าฟังก์ชันที่ให้มา
เป็นค่าคงที่หรือสมดุล
สังเกตว่านี่ไม่ใช่วิธีธรรมชาติในการขยายปัญหาพาริตี้
สำหรับฟังก์ชันในรูปแบบนี้
ตรงนี้เราไม่ได้คำนวณพาริตี้ งานคือเอาต์พุต 0 ถ้า
ฟังก์ชัน f เป็นค่าคงที่
และ 1 ถ้าฟังก์ชัน f เป็นแบบสมดุล
สิ่งแรกที่ต้องสังเกตเกี่ยวกับ
ปัญหานี้คือเมื่อ n จำนวนบิตอินพุตของ
ฟังก์ชัน f มีค่าอย่างน้อย 2
มีตัวเลือกของฟังก์ชันที่ไม่ใช่ค่าคงที่และไม่ใช่แบบสมดุล
ตัวอย่างเช่น นี่คือ
ฟังก์ชันจาก 2 บิตไป 1 บิตที่ไม่ใช่ค่าคงที่และไม่ใช่แบบสมดุล
มันไม่ใช่ค่าคงที่เพราะค่าไบนารีทั้งสอง
ปรากฏในเอาต์พุต และมันไม่ใช่แบบสมดุล
เพราะค่าเอาต์พุตสองค่า
ปรากฏด้วยความถี่ต่างกัน 0 ปรากฏสามครั้ง
และ 1 ปรากฏแค่ครั้งเดียว
เพื่อจะเป็นแบบสมดุล
เอาต์พุต 0 และ 1 ต้องปรากฏจำนวนครั้ง
เท่ากันพอดี
ข้อเท็จจริงที่ว่ามีฟังก์ชันที่ไม่ใช่ค่าคงที่และไม่ใช่แบบสมดุลเมื่อ n อย่างน้อย 2 ก็ไม่เป็นไร เราจะถือว่า
ฟังก์ชันแบบนั้น
เป็นอินพุตแบบ "ไม่สนใจ" พูดอีกอย่างก็คือ นี่
เป็นปัญหาที่มีเงื่อนไขสัญญา
และนี่คือคำกล่าว
ที่แม่นยำของปัญหา
เรามีเงื่อนไขสัญญาว่าฟังก์ชันอินพุต f เป็นค่าคงที่หรือสมดุล และเป้าหมายคือหา
ว่ามันเป็นแบบไหน
และเราไม่ต้องรับผิดชอบสิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นถ้าอินพุต
ไม่เป็นไปตามเงื่อนไขสัญญา
อัลกอริทึม Deutsch-Jozsa
ที่แก้ปัญหานี้ คือรัน circuit Deutsch-Jozsa ก่อน แล้วเอาต์พุต 0
ถ้าสตริงที่เรา
ได้จากการวัดเป็นสตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมด
และเอาต์พุต 1 ถ้าไม่ใช่
อีกวิธีหนึ่งในการพูดคือเราเอาต์พุต OR ของ
บิตที่เราวัด
เพื่อวิเคราะห์อัลกอริทึม Deutsch-Jozsa มันจะเป็นประโยชน์ที่จะ
ใช้เวลาสักครู่คิดเกี่ยวกับ Hadamard gate
เราสามารถอธิบายการดำเนินการ Hadamard
เป็นเมทริกซ์ได้แน่นอน แต่เรายังสามารถอธิบาย
มันในแง่ของการกระทำ
บนสถานะฐานมาตรฐาน
อย่างที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้
สมการสองสมการนี้สามารถ
รวมเป็นสมการเดียว ซึ่งอธิบายว่าการดำเนินการ
Hadamard ทำงานอย่างไรสำหรับ a ที่เป็นค่า
ไบนารีใดค่าหนึ่ง
และเราสามารถไปไกลกว่านั้นอีกนิด และแสดงสิ่งที่
เราได้เป็นผลรวมแบบนี้
โดยใช้สูตรนั้น เราสามารถหาสูตรที่อธิบายว่าชั้น
ของ Hadamard gate ทำงานอย่างไร ที่เราทำ Hadamard
gate ตัวหนึ่งบนแต่ละ qubit จาก n qubit
ตรงนี้เราอธิบายการกระทำนี้
บนสถานะฐานมาตรฐาน
และเพื่อให้ชัดเจนเกี่ยวกับสัญกรณ์ เมื่อเราเขียน h เทนเซอร์ n แบบนี้ ที่ส่วนเทนเซอร์ n เป็นตัวยก
สิ่งที่เราหมายถึงคือเทนเซอร์โปรดักต์
n ชั้นของ H กับตัวเอง หรือพูดอีกอย่าง n สำเนา
ของ h ทั้งหมดเทนเซอร์เข้าด้วยกัน
เรากำลังทำการดำเนินการนี้
บนสถานะฐานมาตรฐาน และตรงนี้ผมทำตาม
ข้อตกลงที่ Qiskit ใช้
ในการจัดดัชนีสตริงไบนารี เพราะเป็นจังหวะที่ดี
ในการแนะนำข้อตกลงนั้น
ดังนั้น x0 เป็นบิต x1 เป็นบิต
และต่อไปเรื่อยๆ รวมทั้งหมด n บิต และบิตถูกจัดลำดับตาม
ที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้บนหน้าจอ
คุณสามารถคิดว่า
วิธีจัดดัชนีบิตแบบนี้ตรงกับความสำคัญของมัน ถ้าเราดูสตริงว่าเป็นตัวแทน
ของจำนวนเต็ม
ในรูปแบบไบนารี เป็นต้น
ถ้าเราทำ Hadamard gate
บนแต่ละ qubit เหล่านี้ เราสามารถแสดงผลลัพธ์เป็นเทนเซอร์โปรดักต์ n ชั้น
ของ Hadamard gate ที่ทำบนแต่ละ qubit แล้วเราก็ใช้สูตรกับแต่ละตัวคูณเทนเซอร์
และตรงนี้เราใช้
ชื่อ y และ ลบ 1 ลงไปจนถึง y1 แทน b ในสูตร
ดังนั้นเหล่านี้เป็นค่าไบนารี และเราต้องใช้ชื่อใหม่ทุกครั้งที่ใช้สูตร
ถ้าเราขยายทุกอย่างออกมาโดยใช้คุณสมบัติหลายเชิงเส้น
ของเทนเซอร์โปรดักต์ เราจะได้นิพจน์
ที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้
และเพื่อให้ชัดเจน ผลรวม n ตัวถูก
รวมเป็นผลรวมเดียว แต่เรายังคงรวม
ทุกค่าที่เป็นไปได้
สำหรับค่าไบนารีแต่ละตัว
ทีนี้มาจัดระเบียบสิ่งต่างๆ เพื่อให้เราไปไกลกว่านี้อีกนิด
และขั้นตอนถัดไปคือ
แนะนำการดำเนินการใหม่บนสตริงที่เรียกว่าดอทโปรดักต์ไบนารี
นี่เป็นการดำเนินการบนสตริงไบนารีที่มีความยาวเท่ากัน
และดอทโปรดักต์ไบนารีของสตริง x กับ y สองตัว
ที่มีความยาวเท่ากันคือ eXclusive OR หรือพาริตี้
ของผลคูณของบิตแต่ละตัว
คุณอาจพูดได้ว่ามันคือ XOR ของ AND เชิงตรรกะของบิตแต่ละตัว เพราะ AND เป็น
สิ่งเดียวกับผลคูณ
สำหรับค่าไบนารี อีกวิธีหนึ่งในการอธิบาย
คือมันเป็น 1 หรือ 0
ขึ้นอยู่กับว่า
ผลรวมของผลคูณของบิตแต่ละตัวเป็นคี่หรือคู่
มันคล้ายกับอินเนอร์โปรดักต์มากถ้าเราคิดว่าสตริง
เป็นเวกเตอร์ของค่าไบนารี แต่ที่เราคำนวณ Modulo-2
หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือ เราเอาเศษจากการหารด้วย 2
แต่มันไม่ใช่อินเนอร์โปรดักต์จริงๆ ดังนั้นมันสมควรได้ชื่ออื่น
ในกรณีนี้ เราสามารถใช้ดอทโปรดักต์
ไบนารีเพื่อทำให้สูตรสำหรับการกระทำของชั้น Hadamard gate
บนสถานะฐานมาตรฐานกระชับขึ้น และนี่คือตรงนี้
เราใช้ข้อเท็จจริงที่ว่า
เนื่องจากผลรวมนี้ตรงนี้ปรากฏใน
เลขยกกำลังของลบ 1
สิ่งที่สำคัญมีแค่
ว่ามันเป็นคู่หรือคี่ แต่นอกจากนั้น มันก็แค่เวอร์ชันย่อ
ของสูตรของเรา
อนึ่ง ดอทโปรดักต์
ไบนารีเป็นแบบสมมาตร ในแง่ที่ว่า x จุด
y กับ y จุด x เท่ากัน
ดังนั้นเราสามารถสลับ
ลำดับได้เมื่อไหร่ก็ตามที่มันมีประโยชน์
และตอนนี้ที่เรามีสูตรนั้นแล้ว มันจะค่อนข้างง่ายที่จะวิเคราะห์
circuit Deutsch-Jozsa
เราเริ่มด้วย n qubit ในสถานะ 0 และ qubit ล่างในสถานะ 1 และเราทำ Hadamard
gate บนทุกตัว
ดังนั้นนี่คือสถานะของ
n + 1 qubit ที่เราได้
เราจัดการ
qubit ล่างแยกต่างหากเพราะมันจะสะดวก
และอีกครั้ง เราจะเห็นปรากฏการณ์
เฟสคิกแบ็คเกิดขึ้น
เราได้นิพจน์นี้
โดยใช้สูตรของเรา ที่เราแทนที่
สตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมดสำหรับ x และแทนที่ x สำหรับ y
โดยสังเกตว่าดอทโปรดักต์
ไบนารีของสตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมดกับสตริงใดๆ คือ 0
แต่เราก็สามารถให้เหตุผลโดยตรงได้เหมือนกัน เราทำเทนเซอร์
โปรดักต์ของ n สถานะบวก และนี่คือสิ่งที่เราได้
เทนเซอร์กับสถานะลบ จากนั้น UF gate ถูกทำ และนี่คือที่ปรากฏการณ์
เฟสคิกแบ็คเกิดขึ้น
ค่า f ของ x ถูก
XOR ลงบนสถานะลบสำหรับแต่ละ x ในผลรวม
ดังนั้น f ของ x ถูกเตะเข้าไปในเฟส
ตอนนี้เราทำ
ชั้น Hadamard gate อีกชั้นบน n qubit บน และคราวนี้ เรา
ต้องใช้สูตรจริงๆ
และเมื่อเราใช้มันและทำ
การทำให้ง่ายขึ้นนิดหน่อย เราได้สถานะนี้ตรงนี้
นั่นคือสถานะสุดท้ายของเรา
ก่อนการวัด
สถานะดูซับซ้อนนิดหน่อย และมันยากที่จะทำให้ง่ายขึ้น เพราะเราไม่รู้
อะไรจริงๆ เกี่ยวกับฟังก์ชัน f
แต่จำไว้ว่า สิ่งที่
เราต้องรู้จริงๆ คือการวัด
ให้ผลลัพธ์เป็น 0 ทั้งหมดหรือเปล่า
เพราะนั่นคือสิ่งที่กำหนดว่าคำตอบของเราต่อปัญหาคืออะไร
ถ้าเราเห็นว่าทุก
ผลลัพธ์การวัดเป็น 0 เราสรุปว่าฟังก์ชันเป็นค่าคงที่
และถ้าผลลัพธ์การวัด
ตัวใดตัวหนึ่งเป็น 1 เราสรุปว่าฟังก์ชันเป็นแบบสมดุล
มาคำนวณความน่าจะเป็นที่จะได้สตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมด
จากการวัด
และกลายเป็นว่านั่นเป็นผลลัพธ์เดียวที่คำนวณได้ง่ายจริงๆ เพราะดอทโปรดักต์
ไบนารีของสตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมด
กับสตริงใดๆ เป็นศูนย์ ถ้าเราตรวจสอบเวกเตอร์ของเราและ
เราคิดว่าจะเกิดอะไรขึ้นเมื่อ y เป็นสตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมด
เราได้นิพจน์ตรงนี้
สำหรับความน่าจะเป็นที่จะได้สตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมด
จากการวัด
และพิจารณาสองกรณีที่เป็นไปได้ที่ f เป็นค่าคงที่และ f เป็นแบบสมดุล เราเห็นว่าความน่าจะเป็นที่จะ
ได้สตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมดคือ 1
ในกรณีที่ f เป็นค่าคงที่ และศูนย์เมื่อ f เป็นแบบสมดุล
เมื่อ f เป็นค่าคงที่ ผลรวมจะเป็น 2 ยกกำลัง
n หรือลบ 2 ยกกำลัง n และหารด้วย 2 ยกกำลัง n
แล้วเอาค่าสัมบูรณ์
ยกกำลังสองจะได้ 1
และเมื่อ f เป็นแบบสมดุล ผลรวมเท่ากับ 0
นั่นเป็นเพราะเราจะได้
บวก 1 กับลบ 1 จำนวนเท่ากัน
ดังนั้นมันหักล้างกันหมด
นั่นแหละ อัลกอริทึม Deutsch-Jozsa
แก้ปัญหา Deutsch-Jozsa โดยใช้การสอบถามเพียงครั้งเดียว
และไม่มีข้อผิดพลาด สมมติว่าการดำเนินการ
ทำอย่างสมบูรณ์แบบทั้งหมด มันถูกต้องทุกครั้ง
แล้วมันเปรียบเทียบกับ
สิ่งที่เราทำได้แบบคลาสสิกอย่างไร?
ถ้าเรายืนยันว่าต้องเป็น
อัลกอริทึมแบบกำหนดได้ที่ได้คำตอบ
ถูกต้องทุกครั้ง ในกรณีที่แย่ที่สุด
เราต้องการ 2 ยกกำลัง n ลบ 1 บวก 1 การสอบถาม และนั่นเป็นเพราะเรา
ต้องสอบถามฟังก์ชัน
บนมากกว่าครึ่งของอินพุตเพื่อให้แน่ใจเกี่ยวกับคำตอบ
แม้แต่ถ้าเราสอบถามฟังก์ชันบน 2 ยกกำลัง n ลบ 1
สตริงอินพุตที่ต่างกัน มันเป็นไปได้ที่เราจะ
เห็นค่าเอาต์พุตเดียวกัน
ทุกครั้ง และนั่นอาจเป็นเพราะ
ฟังก์ชันเป็นค่าคงที่ หรืออาจเป็นว่ามันเป็นแบบสมดุลจริงๆ
และเราแค่โชคร้ายมากที่เห็นค่าเอาต์พุต
เดียวกันทุกครั้ง
ดังนั้นนั่นเป็นข้อได้เปรียบขนาดใหญ่
ของควอนตัมเหนือคลาสสิก การสอบถามเพียงครั้งเดียวเทียบกับ
การสอบถามจำนวนเลขยกกำลัง
อย่างไรก็ตาม ถ้าเราใช้
อัลกอริทึมการสอบถามแบบความน่าจะเป็น และเรายอมรับความน่าจะเป็นเล็กน้อยที่มันจะตอบผิด
จริงๆ แล้วเราต้องการแค่การสอบถามไม่กี่ครั้ง
โดยเฉพาะ ถ้าเรา
เลือกสตริง k ตัวแบบสุ่มและประเมินฟังก์ชัน
บนสตริงสุ่มเหล่านั้น
เราก็ค่อนข้างจะสามารถหาคำตอบที่ถูกต้องได้
โดยเฉพาะ เราตอบ 0 หรือค่าคงที่เมื่อเราได้ค่าฟังก์ชัน
เดียวกันทุกครั้ง และ 1 หรือสมดุล
เมื่อเราเห็น
ค่าฟังก์ชันที่ต่างกันสองค่า
ถ้าเราทำแบบนั้น เราจะถูกต้องเสมอเมื่อ
ฟังก์ชันเป็นค่าคงที่ เพราะแน่นอนว่าเราจะเห็นค่าเอาต์พุต
เดียวกันเสมอในกรณีนี้
และถ้า f เป็นแบบสมดุล เราจะเห็น
ค่าเอาต์พุตที่ต่างกันสองค่าได้มากทีเดียว
โอกาสที่เราไม่เห็น
ค่าเอาต์พุตทั้งสองในกรณีนี้ เท่ากับโอกาสที่เราโยนเหรียญ k ครั้ง
แล้วได้ผลลัพธ์
เดียวกันทุกครั้ง
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้าเรา
ตั้ง k เท่ากับ 11 ความน่าจะเป็นที่จะได้คำตอบผิดน้อยกว่าหนึ่งในสิบของเปอร์เซ็นต์
โดยเฉพาะเมื่อเราพิจารณาข้อเท็จจริงที่ว่าคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมจะไม่สมบูรณ์แบบในความเป็นจริง เราไม่ได้
ข้อได้เปรียบขนาดใหญ่มากตรงนี้จริงๆ
แต่เรากำลังก้าวหน้า และเราก็มีข้อได้เปรียบที่วัดได้ของควอนตัมเหนือคลาสสิกที่เกินกว่าอัลกอริทึมของ Deutsch
เรายังสามารถใช้ circuit Deutsch-Jozsa เพื่อแก้ปัญหาการสอบถามอื่นที่เรียกว่าปัญหา Bernstein-Vazirani
นี่คือคำกล่าวของปัญหานั้น อินพุตเป็นฟังก์ชัน
จาก n บิตไป 1 บิต เหมือนกับปัญหา Deutsch-Jozsa
และอีกครั้ง มันเป็นปัญหาที่มีเงื่อนไขสัญญา
คราวนี้ เงื่อนไขสัญญาคือมีสตริง n บิต s บางตัวที่ฟังก์ชัน f
ทำงานตามที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้
ที่เอาต์พุตถูกกำหนด
โดยดอทโปรดักต์ไบนารีของอินพุตกับสตริง s นี้
และเป้าหมายก็แค่
หาสตริง s ดังนั้นเราสามารถจินตนาการว่า
สตริง s ถูกซ่อนอยู่ในแง่หนึ่ง
แต่เราสามารถเรียนรู้เกี่ยวกับมัน
โดยการสอบถาม f และเป้าหมายของเราคือหา
สตริงที่ซ่อนนี้
ให้ชัดเจน ฟังก์ชันส่วนใหญ่
จะไม่เป็นไปตามเงื่อนไขสัญญานี้ แต่เหมือนเคย เราสนใจแค่
ฟังก์ชันอินพุตที่เป็นไปตามเงื่อนไข
ปรากฏว่า circuit Deutsch-Jozsa แก้ปัญหานี้ได้
ทันทีเลย
ถ้าเรารันมันสำหรับ
ฟังก์ชันที่เรามีตรงนี้ ที่เป็นไปตาม
เงื่อนไขสัญญาสำหรับสตริง s บางตัว การวัดจะเผยสตริง s
โดยไม่ต้องมีการประมวลผลภายหลัง
มาดูว่ามันทำงานอย่างไร
เราวิเคราะห์
circuit Deutsch-Jozsa ไปแล้ว ดังนั้นเราสามารถ
ข้ามไปที่ตอนจบได้เลย
นี่คือนิพจน์ที่เรา
ได้จากก่อนหน้าสำหรับสถานะก่อนการวัด และนิพจน์นั้น
ใช้ได้สำหรับฟังก์ชัน f ใดๆ ก็ตาม
และตอนนี้ ถ้าเราแทนค่า
สิ่งที่เรามีเงื่อนไขสัญญาเกี่ยวกับฟังก์ชัน f แล้วทำให้ง่ายขึ้น
เราจะได้สถานะลบ
สำหรับ qubit ล่าง เทนเซอร์กับ cat s สำหรับ n qubit บน
แล้วเราก็ได้ s เมื่อเราวัด
มีงานบางอย่างที่ต้องทำเพื่อทำการทำให้ง่ายขึ้น
ที่ผมแสดงตรงนี้ และผมจะไม่ลงรายละเอียดในวิดีโอนี้
แต่มีรายละเอียดเพิ่มเติมเกี่ยวกับมันในเนื้อหาตำราสำหรับซีรีส์นี้ ซึ่งคุณสามารถหาได้โดยตามลิงก์ในคำอธิบายของวิดีโอ
หรือลองทำเอง
เพื่อฝึกซ้อม
สิ่งที่เราพบคือ
circuit Deutsch-Jozsa แก้ปัญหา Bernstein-Vazirani
ด้วยการสอบถามเพียงครั้งเดียว
ไม่ยากเกินไปที่จะแสดงว่า
อัลกอริทึมแบบคลาสสิกใดๆ ไม่ว่าจะเป็นแบบกำหนดได้
หรือแบบความน่าจะเป็น ต้องการอย่างน้อย n การสอบถาม
เพื่อแก้ปัญหา Bernstein-Vazirani ด้วยเหตุผลง่ายๆ ว่าเราต้องการ n บิตของ
ข้อมูลเพื่อกู้คืน s
และแต่ละการสอบถามให้เรา
อย่างมากที่สุด 1 บิตของข้อมูล
ดังนั้นเราได้ข้อได้เปรียบอีกอย่างของควอนตัมเหนือคลาสสิก
สำหรับอัลกอริทึมการสอบถาม การสอบถามครั้งเดียวสำหรับอัลกอริทึมควอนตัม
n การสอบถามสำหรับอัลกอริทึมแบบคลาสสิก
ควรใช้เวลาสักครู่เพื่อพูดเกี่ยวกับ
ศัพท์ที่ใช้ในบริบทของปัญหานี้ และนิดหน่อยเกี่ยวกับประวัติศาสตร์
บางคนเรียกอัลกอริทึมที่ผมเพิ่งอธิบายว่าเป็นอัลกอริทึม Bernstein-Vazirani แต่มันจริงๆ แค่
circuit Deutsch-Jozsa
และนั่นเป็นสิ่งที่
ถูกระบุไว้อย่างชัดเจนในงานของ Bernstein กับ Vazirani
ดังนั้นมันแปลกนิดหน่อยที่มันถูกเรียกว่าอัลกอริทึม
Bernstein-Vazirani เพราะมันค่อนข้างเป็นสิ่งเดียวกับอัลกอริทึม Deutsch-Jozsa
ลบการประมวลผลภายหลัง แต่ Bernstein กับ Vazirani
ไปไกลกว่านั้นอีกขั้น
พวกเขานิยาม
เวอร์ชันแบบเรียกซ้ำของปัญหานี้ ที่คุณต้อง
แก้ปัญหา Bernstein-Vazirani หลายอินสแตนซ์
เพื่อปลดล็อคอินสแตนซ์ใหม่ของปัญหาที่ถูกจัดเรียงใน
รูปแบบคล้ายต้นไม้ที่ซับซ้อน
มันเป็นปัญหาที่ถูกสร้างขึ้นมามาก แต่ประเด็นคือโดยการ
นิยามปัญหาในแบบนี้ พวกเขาสามารถขยาย
ช่องว่างหนึ่งเทียบกับ n การสอบถามระหว่างควอนตัมกับคลาสสิกออกไปได้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ
และสิ่งที่พวกเขาได้มาคือ
ตัวอย่างแรกที่รู้จักของข้อได้เปรียบที่เรียกว่าซูเปอร์พหุนามของควอนตัมเหนืออัลกอริทึมแบบความน่าจะเป็น
เวอร์ชันแบบเรียกซ้ำของ
ปัญหา Bernstein-Vazirani ยังกลายเป็นเรื่องน่าสนใจมากในภายหลัง
ในทฤษฎีความซับซ้อนเชิงการคำนวณด้วยเหตุผลต่างๆ
อย่างไรก็ตาม ประเด็นคือ
Bernstein กับ Vazirani สมควรได้รับการยกย่องสำหรับผลงานสำคัญของพวกเขา
แต่จริงๆ แล้วมันไม่สมเหตุสมผล
ที่จะเรียกนี่ว่าอัลกอริทึม Bernstein-Vazirani มันก็แค่
อัลกอริทึม Deutsch-Jozsa
ในส่วนสุดท้ายของบทเรียน เราจะดู
อัลกอริทึมการสอบถามควอนตัมอีกตัวที่เรียกว่าอัลกอริทึมของ Simon
คุณจะเห็นความคล้ายคลึงชัดเจน
ระหว่างอัลกอริทึมนี้กับอัลกอริทึม Deutsch-Jozsa แต่มันต่างกัน และที่สำคัญกว่า
มันเผยให้เห็นข้อได้เปรียบที่แข็งแกร่งกว่ามากของควอนตัมเหนือคลาสสิก
สำหรับอัลกอริทึมการสอบถาม
โดยเฉพาะ มันให้เรา
ข้อได้เปรียบแบบเลขยกกำลังที่พิสูจน์ได้ของควอนตัมเหนืออัลกอริทึมแบบคลาสสิก แม้แต่แบบความน่าจะเป็น
ปัญหาที่มันแก้ค่อนข้างเทียมสักหน่อย และมันยากที่จะจินตนาการสถานการณ์ที่การแก้
ปัญหานี้จะมีประโยชน์
แต่มันเป็นแรงบันดาลใจโดยตรง
ให้กับ Peter Shor ค้นพบอัลกอริทึมควอนตัม
สำหรับการแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็ม
และนั่นสนับสนุนอย่างมาก
แนวคิดของโมเดลการสอบถามเป็นจานเพาะเชื้อที่แนวคิด
อัลกอริทึมควอนตัมสามารถพัฒนาได้
เริ่มกันด้วยปัญหาการสอบถามที่อัลกอริทึมของ Simon แก้ ซึ่งอย่างที่คุณอาจเดาได้
เรียกว่าปัญหาของ Simon
นี่คือคำกล่าวของปัญหา และเราจะต้องแกะมันออกเพื่อทำความเข้าใจว่ามันเกี่ยวกับอะไร
สิ่งแรกที่
สังเกตคือคราวนี้ ฟังก์ชันอินพุต f แปลงสตริง n
บิตไปเป็นสตริง m บิต
ที่ m เป็นจำนวนเต็มบวกที่ไม่เท่ากับหนึ่งโดยทั่วไป
มันเป็นปัญหาที่มีเงื่อนไขสัญญา และเหมือนกับปัญหา Bernstein-Vazirani เงื่อนไขสัญญาเกี่ยวข้องกับสตริง s บางตัวที่เราสามารถมองว่าเป็นสตริงที่ซ่อนอยู่
และเหมือนกับ
ปัญหา Bernstein-Vazirani เป้าหมายคือเอาต์พุต
สตริงที่ซ่อนนี้ s
เงื่อนไขสัญญา
ซับซ้อนกว่าคราวนี้ มาแยกมันออก
และทำความเข้าใจว่ามันบอกอะไร
เริ่มจากแค่อ่านมัน มันบอกว่ามีสตริง s ที่มีความยาวเท่ากับ n
ซึ่งเงื่อนไข "ถ้า"
และ "ก็ต่อเมื่อ" ที่เฉพาะเจาะจงเป็นจริงสำหรับทุกตัวเลือกของสตริง n บิต x กับ y
โดยเฉพาะ ต้อง
เป็นกรณีที่ f ของ x เท่ากับ f ของ y ก็ต่อเมื่อหนึ่งใน
สองความเป็นไปได้เป็นจริง
ความเป็นไปได้แรกคือ x เท่ากับ y และความเป็นไปได้ที่สองคือโดยการทำ
eXclusive OR แบบทีละบิตของ x
กับสตริงที่ซ่อน s เราได้ Y
กลายเป็นว่านี่เป็น
เงื่อนไขสัญญาที่ค่อนข้างเข้มงวด ในแง่ที่ว่าฟังก์ชันส่วนใหญ่
ไม่เป็นไปตามเงื่อนไข
เฉพาะฟังก์ชันที่พิเศษมากเท่านั้น
ที่เป็นไปตามเงื่อนไขนี้
ทีนี้ เพื่อให้เข้าใจเงื่อนไขสัญญานี้ดีขึ้น และด้วยเหตุนี้ตัวปัญหาเอง เราจะพิจารณาสองกรณีหลัก
กรณีแรกคือ s
เป็นสตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมด
ในกรณีนี้ เราสามารถทำให้คำกล่าว "ถ้า"
และ "ก็ต่อเมื่อ" ในเงื่อนไขสัญญาง่ายขึ้น เพราะ eXclusive OR แบบทีละบิต
ของสตริง x ใดๆ
กับสตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมด
ก็แค่สตริง x เอง
ดังนั้นเงื่อนไขจะง่ายขึ้น
เป็น f ของ x เท่ากับ f ของ y ก็ต่อเมื่อ x เท่ากับ y
และนั่นก็เป็นอีกวิธีหนึ่งในการพูดว่า f เป็นฟังก์ชันแบบหนึ่งต่อหนึ่ง
พูดอีกอย่าง สตริง f ของ x ต้องไม่ซ้ำกัน
สำหรับแต่ละสตริง x ที่เป็นไปได้
ดังนั้นถ้า f เป็นฟังก์ชันแบบหนึ่งต่อหนึ่ง เงื่อนไขสัญญาก็เป็นไปตามเงื่อนไขจริง โดยเฉพาะสำหรับ s ที่เป็น
สตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมด
และในกรณีนี้ นั่นคือ
เอาต์พุตที่ถูกต้อง
กรณีที่สองคือ s
ไม่ใช่สตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมด และสิ่งที่นี่บอกคือฟังก์ชัน f ต้องเป็นแบบสองต่อหนึ่ง
ดังนั้นสำหรับสตริงอินพุต x ทุกตัว มีอีกสตริงเดียวที่ f แปลงไปเป็นสตริง
เดียวกับที่ x แปลงไป
และยิ่งกว่านั้น อีกสตริงนั้น
ต้องเป็นสตริงที่เราได้จากการทำ eXclusive OR
แบบทีละบิตของ x กับ s
อีกวิธีหนึ่งในการพูดนี้
คือสตริง n บิตทุกตัว x มีคู่หู และคู่หูนั้นคือสตริงที่เราได้
จากการทำ eXclusive OR แบบทีละบิตกับ s
คู่หูสองตัวใดๆ ก็ตามต้องให้
เราสตริงเอาต์พุตเดียวกันถ้าเราเสียบมันเข้า f และไม่มีสตริงอื่นที่ได้รับอนุญาตให้ให้
สตริงเอาต์พุตเดียวกันนั้น
ดังนั้นเหล่านี้จำเป็นต้องเป็นสตริงที่แตกต่างกันที่คู่หูผลิตออกมา
นี่คือตัวอย่างของฟังก์ชันแบบนี้ที่อธิบายโดยตารางค่า
นี่เป็นฟังก์ชัน
จาก 3 บิตไป 5 บิต
ถ้าเราจ้องตาราง
ค่านี้สักพัก เราจะพบว่าเงื่อนไขสัญญา
เป็นไปตามเงื่อนไขสำหรับสตริง 011
000 กับ 011 เป็นคู่หูกัน การ XOR ตัวใดตัวหนึ่ง
ด้วย s ให้เราอีกตัว
และมันให้ค่าเอาต์พุตเดียวกัน ซึ่งคือ 10011 ในกรณีนี้ และไม่มีสตริงอื่นที่ผลิต
สตริงเอาต์พุตเดียวกัน
001 กับ 010 เป็นคู่หูกัน เพราะการ XOR
ตัวใดตัวหนึ่งด้วย s ให้อีกตัว และมันผลิตค่าเอาต์พุตเดียวกัน
ซึ่งอีกครั้ง ไม่ได้ถูกผลิต
โดยสตริงอื่น
และสถานการณ์ก็
คล้ายกันสำหรับ 100 กับ 111 รวมถึง 101 กับ 110
ดังนั้นถ้าอินพุตของ
ปัญหาเป็นฟังก์ชันนี้ คำตอบที่ถูกต้องคือสตริง 011
อย่างที่ผมบอกไว้ก่อนหน้า ฟังก์ชันส่วนใหญ่ไม่เป็นไปตามเงื่อนไขสัญญานี้ มันเป็นเงื่อนไขที่เฉพาะเจาะจงมาก
ยังควรสังเกตด้วยว่า
ถ้าเงื่อนไขสัญญาเป็นไปตามเงื่อนไข มันจะเป็นไปตามเงื่อนไขสำหรับสตริง s เพียงตัวเดียวเท่านั้น
ดังนั้นมีคำตอบที่ถูกต้อง
เพียงคำตอบเดียวเสมอสำหรับปัญหานี้
นั่นคือปัญหาของ Simon อย่างที่ผมบอก มันยากที่จะจินตนาการสถานการณ์จริงที่คุณจะอยากแก้ปัญหานี้
แต่นั่นไม่ใช่ประเด็น ประเด็นคือพยายามหาว่าคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมเก่งอะไร และปรากฏว่ามันเหนือกว่ามาก
กว่าอัลกอริทึมแบบคลาสสิกสำหรับ
การแก้ปัญหาเฉพาะนี้
ทีนี้มาดู
อัลกอริทึมของ Simon ซึ่งแก้ปัญหาของ Simon
อัลกอริทึมประกอบด้วย
การรัน circuit ควอนตัมที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้หลายครั้ง ตามด้วย
ขั้นตอนการประมวลผลภายหลังแบบคลาสสิก
และเราจะเจาะจงมากขึ้นว่าหลาย
ครั้งหมายความว่าอะไรอีกสักพัก
circuit ดูคล้ายกับ
circuit Deutsch-Jozsa มาก คราวนี้เพราะฟังก์ชัน
f แปลง n บิตไป m บิต
query gate ต่างออกไป แทนที่จะเป็นแค่
qubit เดียวข้างล่าง ตอนนี้เรามี m qubit ข้างล่าง
และ n ข้างบนเหมือนเดิม
ข้อแตกต่างสำคัญคือเรา
ไม่ได้ตั้งสถานะลบหรือสถานะลบหลายตัวข้างล่าง
qubit ล่างเหล่านี้ทั้งหมด
ถูกกำหนดค่าเริ่มต้นเป็นสถานะ 0 และสถานะเหล่านั้นเข้า
query gate โดยตรง
ดังนั้นจะไม่มีเฟสคิกแบ็คเกี่ยวข้องในอัลกอริทึมนี้ มันไม่ใช่วิธีที่ตัวนี้ทำงาน
นอกจากความแตกต่าง
ที่ผมเพิ่งพูดถึง มันดูคล้ายกับ
circuit Deutsch-Jozsa มาก
เราทำชั้น Hadamard gate จากนั้นเราทำ query gate หนึ่งครั้ง แล้วเราทำอีก
ชั้นของ Hadamard gate
ตามด้วยการวัดฐานมาตรฐานของ n qubit บน
แนวคิดคือแต่ละครั้งที่เรา
รัน circuit นี้แล้ววัด เราจะได้สตริง y บางตัวที่บอกเราบางอย่าง
เกี่ยวกับสตริงที่ซ่อน s
ในปัญหาของ Simon และโดยการรัน circuit
หลายครั้งอย่างอิสระ เราจะรวบรวมหลักฐาน
ทางสถิติเกี่ยวกับ s เพียงพอ
ที่จะสามารถหาได้ว่า
มันคืออะไรด้วยความมั่นใจสูง
ทีนี้มาวิเคราะห์ circuit
ควอนตัมสำหรับอัลกอริทึมของ Simon เพื่อดูว่ามันทำอะไร
สถานะหลังจาก
ชั้นแรกของ Hadamard gate ดูเป็นแบบนี้ คล้ายกับที่เรามีสำหรับ
อัลกอริทึม Deutsch-Jozsa
ยกเว้นคราวนี้ m qubit ล่างทั้งหมดอยู่ในสถานะ 0
แทนที่จะอยู่ในสถานะลบ
หลังจาก query gate ถูกทำ เราเห็นว่าค่า f ของ x ถูกเขียนลงบน
m qubit ล่างหรือซ้ายสุด
และนั่นเป็นเพราะ f ของ x ถูก XOR ลงบนสตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมด
ดังนั้นอีกครั้ง ไม่มีเฟสคิกแบ็คเกิดขึ้นในอัลกอริทึมนี้
จากนั้นเราทำ
ชั้นที่สองของ Hadamard gate
และใช้สูตรเดิมสำหรับการกระทำของ
ชั้น Hadamard gate บนสถานะ
ฐานมาตรฐาน cat x ในกรณีนี้
อย่างที่มันเป็นในสูตรดั้งเดิม เราได้สถานะนี้ตรงนี้ ที่การกระทำของ Hadamard gate
ถูกทำให้ชัดเจนยิ่งขึ้น แต่ถ้าเราต้องการ เราก็สามารถเขียนสถานะ
ในรูปแบบที่กะทัดรัดกว่าอย่างที่เรามีตรงนี้
ณ จุดนี้ เราวัด n qubit บนเพื่อให้ได้สตริง n บิต y บางตัว และเราแค่ต้องหา
ว่าความน่าจะเป็นคือเท่าไหร่
สำหรับสตริงต่างๆ และนั่นจะช่วยให้เราเข้าใจ
ว่าข้อมูลอะไรที่เราได้จากสตริง y นี้เกี่ยวกับสตริง s
ที่ซ่อนอยู่ภายในฟังก์ชัน f
เราจะต้อง
มีพื้นที่เพิ่มเติมสำหรับสิ่งนี้ และเราจริงๆ ไม่ต้องการ
แผนภาพ circuit อีกแล้ว ดังนั้นมาเอามันออกและให้
พื้นที่เพิ่มเติมสำหรับการวิเคราะห์
นี่คือสถานะก่อน
การวัด ซึ่งเป็นการวัดฐานมาตรฐานของ n qubit บนหรือขวาสุด
ดังนั้นการวัด
ตรงกับ cat ตัวที่สอง
ให้เรากำหนด p ของ y เป็นความน่าจะเป็นที่การวัดให้เราสตริง y สำหรับ y แต่ละตัวที่เป็นไปได้
และถ้าเราทำตามกฎจากบทเรียนที่ 2 เราจะได้ว่าแต่ละความน่าจะเป็นเหล่านี้คือนอร์มยูคลิเดียนกำลังสองของเวกเตอร์ใดก็ตามที่เทนเซอร์
กับสถานะฐานมาตรฐาน
ที่ตรงกับ y ใน
เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมของเรา
ซึ่งให้เรานิพจน์ตรงนี้
ทีนี้ เพื่อให้เข้าใจ
ความน่าจะเป็นเหล่านี้ดีขึ้น เราจะต้องใช้
สัญกรณ์บางอย่าง และคุณอาจคุ้นเคย
กับสัญกรณ์นี้แล้ว
เพราะมันค่อนข้างทั่วไปในคณิตศาสตร์
อย่างแรก เมื่อเราอ้างถึง
เรนจ์ของฟังก์ชัน f เราหมายถึงเซตของสตริงทั้งหมดที่ออกมาจากฟังก์ชันนี้ได้
ดังนั้นมันคือเซตของ f ของ x ทั้งหมดที่ครอบคลุมทุกตัวเลือก
ที่เป็นไปได้ของสตริงอินพุต x
อย่างที่สอง เราจะใช้สัญกรณ์นี้ที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้ เพื่อหมายถึงเซตของสตริงอินพุต x ทั้งหมด
ที่ f แปลงไปเป็นสตริง z ที่กำหนด สำหรับ
z ใดก็ตามที่เราจะพิจารณา
มันดูเหมือน
อินเวอร์สของฟังก์ชัน f แต่มันไม่ใช่อินเวอร์สจริงๆ เพราะ f ไม่จำเป็นต้องกลับได้
เรายังเห็นว่าเรามี
เซตเป็นอาร์กิวเมนต์ทางซ้าย และในกรณีนี้ มันเป็นเซตที่มี
แค่สตริง z ตัวเดียว
และนั่นเป็นเบาะแสที่เราต้องการเพื่อรู้ว่าเราไม่ได้พูดถึง
อินเวอร์สของฟังก์ชัน f นี่เรียกว่าพรีอิมเมจ
พรีอิมเมจสามารถ
นิยามได้ทั่วไปมากขึ้นสำหรับเซตใดๆ ที่ให้เป็นอาร์กิวเมนต์ ไม่ใช่แค่เซตที่มี
สมาชิกตัวเดียว
แต่นี่คือทั้งหมดที่เราจะต้องใช้ มันไม่ใช่
สัญกรณ์ที่ดีที่สุดในโลก เพราะมันง่ายที่จะ
สับสนกับอินเวอร์ส
แต่มันชัดเจนพอ
และใช้กันอย่างกว้างขวาง ดังนั้นเราจะใช้มัน
และตอนนี้ถ้าเราใช้สัญกรณ์นี้ เราสามารถเขียนเวกเตอร์ที่เราเอา
นอร์มยูคลิเดียนกำลังสองเพื่อให้ได้ความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับ
การวัดสตริง y แต่ละตัว ใหม่ได้
เราทำสิ่งนี้เพราะเราต้องเห็น
ว่าสัมประสิทธิ์คืออะไรสำหรับแต่ละสถานะฐานมาตรฐาน และนั่นไม่ชัดเจนจาก
นิพจน์ตรงนี้
เพราะโดยทั่วไป เราอาจ
มีหลายตัวเลือกของ x ที่ให้เราสตริง f ของ x เดียวกัน
โดยพื้นฐานแล้ว สิ่งที่เราทำ
คือแยกผลรวมเหนือ x โดยรวมเหนือ
z ทั้งหมดในเรนจ์ของ f ก่อน
แล้วภายในผลรวมนั้น รวมเหนือ x ทั้งหมดในพรีอิมเมจของ z หรือให้แม่นยำกว่า
พรีอิมเมจของเซต
ที่มีสตริง z
นั่นทำให้เราแทนที่ f ของ x ด้วย z ภายใน cat ตรงนี้
และผลรวมเหนือสตริง
x ทั้งหมดที่ f แปลงไปเป็น z แต่ละตัว ถูกรวบรวมเป็น
สัมประสิทธิ์สำหรับแต่ละ cat
เราก็แค่ใส่สตริงลงถัง รวมเหนือถัง แล้วรวมเหนือ
สตริงในแต่ละถัง
แต่นั่นเทียบเท่ากับแค่
รวมเหนือสตริงทั้งหมด
ดังนั้นเราได้นิพจน์ที่เทียบเท่ากับ
ตัวที่เราเริ่มต้น
และตอนนี้เราสามารถคำนวณ
นอร์มยูคลิเดียนกำลังสอง
มันก็แค่ผลรวมของกำลังสองของค่าสัมบูรณ์
ของสัมประสิทธิ์ และดังนั้น เราได้นิพจน์ตรงนี้
สำหรับความน่าจะเป็นของเรา
แน่นอน ให้เวลาตัวเอง
ตรวจสอบสิ่งนี้ ถ้าคุณเลือกที่จะทำ มันต้องใช้เวลาในการคุ้นเคยกับทั้งหมดนี้
และสามารถทำ
การคำนวณเหล่านี้ และยิ่งคุณฝึกซ้อมมากเท่าไหร่ มันก็จะง่ายขึ้นเท่านั้น
จนถึงตอนนี้ เรายัง
ไม่ได้ใช้เงื่อนไขสัญญาในปัญหาของ Simon เลย
การวิเคราะห์ความน่าจะเป็นเหล่านี้ของเราจริงๆ แล้วใช้ได้สำหรับฟังก์ชัน f ใดๆ แต่ตอนนี้ถึงเวลาคิดเกี่ยวกับปัญหาของ Simon
โดยเฉพาะ
เราจะแบ่งสิ่งต่างๆ ออกเป็นสองกรณีเดียวกัน
กับที่เรามีก่อนหน้า
กรณีแรกคือ s
เป็นสตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมด และกรณีที่สองคือ
s ไม่ใช่สตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมด
ในกรณีแรก ที่
s เป็นสตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมด สิ่งต่างๆ ค่อนข้างง่าย
ในกรณีนี้ อย่างที่เราเห็นก่อนหน้า เรามีว่า f เป็นฟังก์ชันแบบหนึ่งต่อหนึ่ง ดังนั้นมีสตริง x เดียว
ที่ถูกแปลงไปยังแต่ละ
สตริง z ในเรนจ์ของ f
นั่นทำให้ค่าสัมบูรณ์กำลังสองของผลรวมเหนือสตริงเหล่านั้นเท่ากับ 1 เพราะมี
พจน์เดียวในผลรวม
มันเป็นบวก 1 หรือลบ 1 แต่ไม่สำคัญว่าจะเป็นค่าไหน เพราะเราเอา
ค่าสัมบูรณ์กำลังสอง และดังนั้นเราได้หนึ่ง
มี 2 ยกกำลัง n
สมาชิกในเรนจ์ของ f และเรารู้เพราะ f เป็นแบบหนึ่งต่อหนึ่ง ดังนั้นมีหนึ่งสตริงใน
เรนจ์สำหรับแต่ละสตริงอินพุต
และถ้าเราประเมินนิพจน์ทั้งหมด เราพบว่าแต่ละสตริง y ปรากฏด้วยความน่าจะเป็น
หนึ่งส่วน 2 ยกกำลัง n
พูดอีกอย่างคือ
การวัดให้เราสตริง y ที่ถูกเลือกแบบสุ่มสม่ำเสมอ
อาจดูไม่มีประโยชน์มาก แต่จริงๆ แล้วเราจะสามารถ
แยกแยะพฤติกรรมนี้จากพฤติกรรมที่เราได้ในกรณี
ที่ s ไม่ใช่สตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมด และเราจะเห็นว่ามันเป็นอย่างไรในไม่ช้า
ตอนนี้ เราแค่สังเกตว่าถ้า
f เป็นไปตามเงื่อนไขสัญญาในปัญหาของ Simon ในกรณีที่ s เป็นสตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมด
ผลลัพธ์ของการวัดเป็นสตริงสุ่มแบบสม่ำเสมอ
ทีนี้มาไปกรณีที่สอง ซึ่งก็คือเงื่อนไข
สัญญาเป็นไปตามเงื่อนไขสำหรับสตริง s ที่ไม่ใช่สตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมด
ในกรณีนี้ ตามที่เราพูดไว้ก่อนหน้า แต่ละสตริง z ในเรนจ์ของ f มีสตริงสองตัวพอดีที่แปลงไปเป็นมัน
เพราะทุกสตริงมีคู่หู และแต่ละคู่ของคู่หู
แปลงไปเป็นสตริงเฉพาะบางตัว และโดยเฉพาะ คู่หูของแต่ละสตริง
คือสตริงที่เราได้จากการ XOR กับ s
ดังนั้นถ้าเราหยิบสตริง
z ใดๆ ในเรนจ์ของ f แล้วให้ชื่อ w กับสตริง
ตัวใดตัวหนึ่งที่ f แปลงไปเป็น z
XOR ของ w กับ s ก็คือ
อีกสตริงที่แปลงไปเป็น z
ดูแค่พจน์เดียวในผลรวมของเราที่ตรงกับสตริง z ในเรนจ์ที่เรามีในใจ
เราเห็นว่าเราสามารถ
เขียนมันชัดเจนขึ้นอย่างที่เรามีตรงนี้
เรามีสตริงสองตัวในพรีอิมเมจของ z คือ w กับ w XOR กับ s
ดังนั้นเราสามารถเขียนผลรวม
ตามที่คุณเห็นบนหน้าจอ และตอนนี้สิ่งที่เราทำได้คือดึงตัวคูณ
ลบ 1 ยกกำลัง w จุด y ออกมา
ตัวคูณนั้นจะเป็น
บวก 1 หรือลบ 1 ดังนั้นมันหายไปเมื่อเรา
เอาค่าสัมบูรณ์
และสิ่งที่เราเหลือคือ
นิพจน์ตรงนี้
รายละเอียดไม่ได้แสดงทั้งหมดตรงนี้ และมันไม่จำเป็น
ต้องชัดเจนว่ามันทำงานแบบนี้ แต่คุณสามารถตรวจสอบว่า
นิพจน์สองตัวนี้เท่ากัน
โดยกลับไปที่นิยาม
ของดอทโปรดักต์ไบนารี และคิดเกี่ยวกับว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นเมื่อสิ่งเหล่านี้อยู่
ในเลขยกกำลังของลบ 1
ไม่ต่างจากสิ่งที่เรามี
สำหรับปัญหา Bernstein-Vazirani
สุดท้าย เราสามารถแยก
นิพจน์นี้ออกเป็นสองกรณี
มันเป็น 4 เมื่อดอทโปรดักต์
ไบนารีของ s กับ y เป็น 0 และเป็น 0 เมื่อดอทโปรดักต์
ไบนารีของ s กับ y เป็น 1
สังเกตโดยเฉพาะว่า
ไม่มีการขึ้นอยู่กับ w หรือ z เลยตรงนี้ มันขึ้นอยู่กับ s กับ y เท่านั้น
เหตุผลที่สิ่งนี้เกิดขึ้น
เป็นเพราะธรรมชาติที่เฉพาะเจาะจงและพิเศษมากของเงื่อนไขสัญญา
โดยพื้นฐานแล้ว นี่คือเหตุผลที่เงื่อนไขสัญญาถูกกำหนดในแบบนี้ เพื่อให้ทุกอย่างออกมาแบบนี้
อีกครั้ง ทุกสตริงมีคู่หู ซึ่งเราได้โดยการ XOR กับ
สตริงที่ซ่อน s ตัวเดียวนี้
และนั่นคือสิ่งที่ทำให้ทั้งหมดนี้เกิดขึ้น
ตอนนี้เราสามารถกลับไปที่
นิพจน์สำหรับความน่าจะเป็นและแทนค่าเข้าไป
เมื่อ s ไม่ใช่สตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมด มี 2 ยกกำลัง n ลบ 1
สมาชิกในเรนจ์ของ f
ซึ่งเป็นครึ่งหนึ่งของ
จำนวนสตริงอินพุต และแทนค่า
ที่เราเพิ่งคำนวณเข้าไปจะให้สูตรตรงนี้
ดังนั้นคราวนี้ y ไม่ใช่
สตริงสุ่มทั้งหมด แต่ y จะสม่ำเสมอเหนือครึ่งหนึ่งพอดีของสตริง n บิต
และโดยเฉพาะ มัน
สม่ำเสมอเหนือสตริงที่มีดอทโปรดักต์
ไบนารีเท่ากับ 0 กับ s
ตอนนี้ที่เรารู้แล้วว่า circuit
สำหรับอัลกอริทึมของ Simon ทำงานอย่างไร และโดยเฉพาะว่า
ความน่าจะเป็นคือเท่าไหร่สำหรับผลลัพธ์การวัดต่างๆ
ยังเหลือที่จะอธิบายว่าสิ่งนี้ช่วยเราแก้ปัญหาของ Simon อย่างไร
สรุปสิ่งที่เราเพิ่งเรียนรู้ ถ้าเป็นกรณีที่ฟังก์ชัน f เป็นไปตามเงื่อนไขสัญญาในปัญหาของ Simon
เมื่อสตริงที่ซ่อน s
เป็นสตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมด เราได้สตริงสุ่มทั้งหมด
จากการวัด
ที่สตริง n บิต y
แต่ละตัวมีโอกาสเท่ากัน
ในทางกลับกัน ถ้าฟังก์ชัน f เป็นไปตามเงื่อนไขสัญญาสำหรับสตริง s ตัวอื่น ตัวที่ไม่เท่ากับ
สตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมด
เราก็ได้สตริงสุ่ม y ที่มีดอทโปรดักต์
ไบนารีเท่ากับ 0 กับ s และในบรรดาสตริงเหล่านั้นทั้งหมด
y แต่ละตัวมีโอกาสเท่ากัน
แต่เราจะไม่มีวันได้สตริง y ที่มีดอทโปรดักต์
ไบนารีเท่ากับ 1 กับ s
คำถามกลายเป็น "นี่เป็นข้อมูลเพียงพอ
ที่จะระบุ s ไหม?" และคำตอบ ตามที่ผม
ได้แนะนำไปแล้ว คือใช่
ถ้าเรารัน
circuit จำนวนครั้งเพียงพอ
โดยเฉพาะ สมมติว่า
เรารัน circuit k ครั้ง ที่ K เท่ากับ n บวก r
ที่ r เป็นจำนวนที่จะควบคุม
โอกาสที่เราจะกู้คืน s ได้
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้า
เราเลือก r เป็น 10 เราจะสำเร็จด้วย
ความน่าจะเป็นมากกว่า 99.9%
ดังนั้นเราไม่ต้องการให้ r มีค่ามากขนาดนั้น
โดยทั่วไป ความน่าจะเป็นของความล้มเหลวน้อยกว่าความน่าจะเป็น
ของการโยนเหรียญที่ยุติธรรม r ครั้งแล้วได้หัวทุกครั้ง
ถ้า 99.9% ยังไม่ดี
พอ ก็ตั้ง r เป็น 20 และโอกาสของความล้มเหลว
น้อยกว่าหนึ่งในล้าน
หรือเลือก r อะไร
ก็ตามที่ทำให้คุณสบายใจ คุณรับประกันคำตอบที่ถูกต้องไม่ได้ แต่คุณสามารถทำให้
ความน่าจะเป็นของข้อผิดพลาดน้อยจนไม่มีนัยสำคัญ
สำหรับทุกจุดประสงค์
ตรงนี้เราตั้งชื่อ
สตริงเหล่านี้ว่า y1 ถึง yk ที่เราใช้ตัวยกเพื่อช่วยตั้งชื่อสตริงเหล่านี้
เพื่อที่เราจะสงวนตัวห้อยไว้อ้างถึงบิต
แต่ละตัวของสตริงเหล่านั้น
ดังนั้นเหล่านี้ไม่ใช่เลขยกกำลัง
หรืออะไรแบบนั้น เหล่านี้แค่เป็นชื่อที่เราให้กับสตริง k ตัวนี้
แต่ละตัวมีความยาว n เพราะเราได้มัน
จากการรัน circuit สำหรับอัลกอริทึมของ Simon
ดังนั้นเราสามารถเขียน
บิตแต่ละตัวของสตริง k ตัวนี้อย่างที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้
สิ่งที่เราทำตอนนี้คือสร้างเมทริกซ์ m ที่แต่ละรายการของเมทริกซ์นี้เป็นบิต และเราได้บิตเหล่านี้จากสตริง
ที่เราเพิ่งวัดมา อย่างที่แสดงตรงนี้
ดังนั้นเมทริกซ์นี้มี k แถวกับ n คอลัมน์ และรายการทั้งหมดเป็นค่าไบนารี
ตอนนี้ เราไม่รู้ว่า s คืออะไร นั่นคือสิ่งที่เราพยายามหา แต่แค่จินตนาการ
สักครู่ว่าเรารู้ s
แล้วเราสร้างเวกเตอร์
คอลัมน์จากบิตของ s อย่างที่แสดงตรงนี้
ถ้าเราคูณเวกเตอร์นั้นด้วย m แล้วเอาผลลัพธ์ modulo-2 หรืออีกวิธีหนึ่งในการพูด
คือเราแทนที่การบวก
ด้วย eXclusive OR เราจะได้
เวกเตอร์ศูนย์ทั้งหมดอย่างแน่นอน
นั่นเป็นเพราะแต่ละ
รายการในเวกเตอร์ผลลัพธ์นี้ไม่ใช่อะไรอื่นนอกจากดอทโปรดักต์
ไบนารีของ s
กับหนึ่งในแถวของ m
ถ้า S บังเอิญเป็นสตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมด เราจะได้เวกเตอร์ศูนย์จากดอทโปรดักต์ไบนารีเสมอ
และถ้า s ไม่ใช่สตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมด เราจะได้สิ่งนี้จากสิ่งที่
เรารู้เกี่ยวกับความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับสตริง y1 ถึง yk ที่จะปรากฏ
โดยเฉพาะ
ดอทโปรดักต์ไบนารีกับ s เป็นศูนย์เสมอสำหรับสตริงเหล่านี้ทั้งหมด
วิธีง่ายๆ ในการพูดคือเวกเตอร์
ที่สร้างจากบิตของ s อยู่ในนัลสเปซของเมทริกซ์ m เสมอ
โดยสมมติว่าเราทำ
เลขคณิตทั้งหมด modulo-2 แต่แน่นอนว่าเราไม่รู้ว่า s คืออะไร
เรากำลังพยายามหา s
แต่สิ่งที่เราทำได้คือคำนวณ
นัลสเปซของเมทริกซ์ m นี้ อีกครั้ง modulo-2
โดยเฉพาะ เราทำได้โดยใช้เทคนิค
การกำจัดแบบ Gaussian ซึ่งเป็นขั้นตอนที่มักสอน
ในวิชาพีชคณิตเชิงเส้นเบื้องต้น
มันทำงานได้ดีเมื่อเราทำเลขคณิตทั้งหมด modulo-2 และสามารถทำได้
อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพด้วยคอมพิวเตอร์
และถ้าเราคำนวณนัลสเปซของ m เมื่อพิจารณาวิธีเฉพาะที่สตริง k ตัวนี้ถูก
เลือกแบบสุ่ม
เราจะสามารถกู้คืน s ได้ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นมากกว่า
1 ลบ 2 ยกกำลังลบ r
ให้เจาะจง สิ่งที่เราจะเห็นด้วยความน่าจะเป็นมากกว่า
1 ลบ 2 ยกกำลังลบ r คือนัลสเปซ
มีเวกเตอร์ศูนย์ทั้งหมด
อย่างที่มันมีเสมอสำหรับทุกเมทริกซ์ รวมถึงเวกเตอร์ที่ตรงกับ s ไม่ว่ามันจะเป็นเวกเตอร์ศูนย์ทั้งหมดหรือไม่
และที่สำคัญที่สุด จะไม่มีเวกเตอร์อื่น
ปรากฏในนัลสเปซ
จริงๆ แล้วไม่ยากเกินไปที่จะพิสูจน์สิ่งนี้ แม้ว่าผมจะไม่ลงรายละเอียด
แนวคิดคือถ้าเรา
มีสตริงอื่นที่ไม่ใช่เวกเตอร์
ศูนย์ทั้งหมดและไม่ใช่ s สตริงสุ่ม
y1 ถึง yk แต่ละตัว
จะทำให้มันหลุด
จากนัลสเปซด้วยความน่าจะเป็นครึ่งหนึ่ง
ดังนั้นหลังจาก k ครั้ง มัน
ไม่น่าจะรอดเลย และจริงๆ แล้ว ไม่มีสตริง
ที่ไม่ควรอยู่ตัวใด
ที่น่าจะรอด และข้อเท็จจริงง่ายๆ
จากทฤษฎีความน่าจะเป็น ที่เรียกว่าขอบเขตยูเนียน สามารถ
ใช้พิสูจน์สิ่งนั้น
ผมไม่ได้อธิบาย
รายละเอียดทั้งหมดตรงนี้ แต่หวังว่าคุณจะเข้าใจแนวคิดว่าโดยการคำนวณ
นัลสเปซ modulo-2 ของเมทริกซ์ m นี้
เราจะกู้คืน s ได้เป็นอย่างมาก และนั่นคือวิธีที่อัลกอริทึมของ Simon
แก้ปัญหาของ Simon
เหลืออีกแค่เรื่องเดียว
ที่จะพูดเกี่ยวกับปัญหาของ Simon และมันเกี่ยวกับความยาก
แบบคลาสสิกของปัญหานี้
นั่นคือ อัลกอริทึมการสอบถามแบบคลาสสิกต้องการการสอบถามกี่ครั้งเพื่อแก้ปัญหาของ Simon?
คำตอบคือ เยอะ โดยทั่วไป
มีคำกล่าวที่แม่นยำ
ต่างๆ ที่สามารถทำได้เกี่ยวกับความยาก
แบบคลาสสิกของปัญหานี้ และนี่คือตัวอย่างหนึ่ง
ถ้าเรามี
อัลกอริทึมการสอบถามแบบความน่าจะเป็นใดๆ และอัลกอริทึมนั้นทำน้อยกว่า 2 ยกกำลัง n ส่วน 2
ลบ 1 ลบ 1 การสอบถาม
ซึ่งเป็นจำนวนการสอบถาม
ที่เป็นเลขยกกำลังใน n อัลกอริทึมนั้นจะล้มเหลว
ในการแก้ปัญหาของ Simon
ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นอย่างน้อยครึ่งหนึ่ง
บางครั้ง การพิสูจน์
ผลลัพธ์แบบเป็นไปไม่ได้แบบนี้อาจท้าทายมาก แต่อันนี้ไม่ยากเกินไปที่จะพิสูจน์
ผ่านการวิเคราะห์
ความน่าจะเป็นเบื้องต้น
ผมจะไม่ทำสิ่งนั้นในวิดีโอบทเรียนนี้ และแค่เน้น
ที่สัญชาตญาณเบื้องหลังมัน
เราพยายามหาสตริงที่ซ่อน s แต่ตราบใดที่เราไม่ได้สอบถามฟังก์ชันบนสตริงสองตัวที่มี
ค่าเอาต์พุตเดียวกัน
เราจะได้ข้อมูลเกี่ยวกับ s
อย่างจำกัดมาก
โดยพื้นฐานแล้ว สิ่งที่เราเรียนรู้มีแค่
ว่าสตริงที่ซ่อน s ไม่ใช่ eXclusive OR ของสตริง
ที่แตกต่างกันสองตัวที่เราสอบถามไปแล้ว
และถ้าเราสอบถามฟังก์ชันด้วยจำนวนการสอบถามน้อยกว่าตัวเลขนี้ ก็ยังมีตัวเลือกของ s จำนวนมาก
ที่ยังไม่ได้ถูกตัดออก
นี่ไม่ใช่การพิสูจน์แบบทางการ
แต่นั่นคือแนวคิดพื้นฐาน
สรุป อัลกอริทึมของ Simon ให้เราข้อได้เปรียบที่น่าทึ่งของควอนตัมเหนือคลาสสิก
ภายในโมเดลการสอบถาม
โดยเฉพาะ อัลกอริทึมของ
Simon แก้ปัญหาของ Simon ด้วยจำนวนการสอบถามที่เป็นเชิงเส้นในจำนวนบิต
อินพุต n ของฟังก์ชัน
ในขณะที่อัลกอริทึมแบบคลาสสิกใดๆ
แม้แต่แบบความน่าจะเป็น ต้องทำจำนวน
การสอบถามที่เป็นเลขยกกำลังใน n
เพื่อแก้ปัญหาของ Simon ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นของความสำเร็จที่สมเหตุสมผล
เป็นความจริงที่ปัญหาของ Simon เป็นปัญหาที่ค่อนข้างเทียม ที่น่าจะไม่มีใคร
อยากแก้จริงๆ
แต่นั่นเป็นเรื่องรอง บางครั้งแนวคิดต้องถูกพัฒนาก่อนที่มันจะถูกนำไปใช้จริง
และจริงๆ แล้ว Peter Shor ได้ระบุอย่างชัดเจนว่าอัลกอริทึมของ Simon เป็นแรงบันดาลใจให้กับอัลกอริทึมควอนตัม
ที่มีชื่อเสียงของเขา
สำหรับการแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็ม ซึ่งเราจะเห็นในอีกสองสามบทเรียน
และนั่นคือจุดจบของบทเรียนที่ 5
ในบทเรียนนี้ เราได้ดู
โมเดลการสอบถามของการคำนวณ และเราเห็นตัวอย่างที่ก้าวหน้าขึ้นเรื่อยๆ
ของอัลกอริทึมควอนตัม
ที่แสดงข้อได้เปรียบเหนืออัลกอริทึมแบบคลาสสิก
ภายในโมเดลนี้
จริงๆ แล้วมีอะไรอีกมากมาย
ที่รู้เกี่ยวกับโมเดลการสอบถามและอัลกอริทึมควอนตัมสำหรับปัญหาอื่นๆ ที่
ผมไม่ได้พูดถึง
ดังนั้นถ้าคุณพบว่า
โมเดลนี้น่าสนใจ ก็มีอีกมาก
ให้เรียนรู้เกี่ยวกับมัน
ขั้นตอนถัดไปของเราคือจะย้าย
ออกจากโมเดลการสอบถามไปสู่โมเดลการคำนวณ
ที่เป็นตัวแทน
ของปัญหาประเภทที่เราอาจหวังจะแก้ในทางปฏิบัติได้มากกว่า
ผมหวังว่าคุณจะมาร่วมกับผมในบทเรียนที่ 6 ที่เราจะเน้นที่
การวางรากฐานสำหรับการศึกษาอัลกอริทึมควอนตัมเป็นหลัก
และจากตรงนั้น เราจะไปที่
อัลกอริทึมควอนตัมเฉพาะบางตัว รวมถึงอัลกอริทึมของ Shor
สำหรับการแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็ม
ในบทเรียนต่อๆ ไป ลาก่อนจนกว่าจะเจอกัน!